I LOVE HITTING THE GAVEL. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO THIS
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE- WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT I'M JOINED
HERE BY MY VICE CHAIR- SO IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM THE HEARING ROOM WE
ALSO HAVE THE OPTION OF
TESTIFYING VIA PHONE LINE. CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING NOW
REPEATED. IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. LET ME SAY IT AGAIN. CALL
IN NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
YOUR SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE NOTE THAT CALL IN
TESTIMONY WILL BE COMBINED FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND
WILL BE TAKEN AFTER BOTH SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRIMARY WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED. PRIMARY WITNESS
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH SIDE.
ALSO PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOURPRIMARY WITNESS COLLEEN IN
. REMAIN A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF TELL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO STATING THEIR NAY
ORGANIZATION. NAY IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE THEIR POSITION ON
THE BILL. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITNESS AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S COMMITTEE TWO OF
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT. WE DON'T
YET HAVE A QUORUM WILL ESTABLISH
THAT- WILL NEED FIVE AND- WE DO
WE ONLY HAVE THREE AT THE MOMENT
SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND HEAR TESTIMONY
ON OUR FIRST BILL- LET'S SEE.
WHO IS THE ORDER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AB NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE DRINKING WATER
ACCESSIBLE WATER BOTTLE REFILL
STATIONS. PLEASE PERCEPT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EVERY OUR CONSUMERS
THROW AWAY TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PLASTIC BOTTLES IN LESS
THAN 30% OF THESE PLASTIC
BOTTLES ARE RECYCLED THIS YEAR
THE CONSUMPTION OF PLASTIC
BOTTLES IS SET TO HIT HALF A
TRILLION THIS OUTWEIGHS
RECYCLING EFFORTS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MASSIVELY JEOPARDIZE
THE ENVIRONMENT ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT NEARLY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LACK ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER. CALIFORNIA FACES
MANY CHALLENGES IN PROVIDING
CLEAN SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. TO ALL OF ITS
CITIZENS INCLUDING ON HOUSE LOW
INCOME AND MINORITY COMMUNITIES
AB NINETEEN FIFTY THREE WILL
REQUIRE THE OWNER OPERATOR OF A
TRANSIT HUB LOCAL PARK. PUBLIC
BUILDING SHOPPING MALL OR GOLF
COURSE TO INSTALL AND MAINTAIN
AT LEAST ONE ACCESSIBLE WATER
BOTTLE REFILL STATION. ENSURING
THE STATIONS ARE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE IMPROVES ACCESSIBILITY
TO DRINKING WATER REDUCES
PLASTIC WASTE AND CREATES
LASTING INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT
FOR CONSUMERS OPTING TO REUSE.
WITH ME I HAVE ELECTED TO CHAVEZ
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND RESPECTFULLY WOULD
REQUEST ABOUT ABOUT. ALL RIGHT
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME'S LEXI CHÁVEZ
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE OF
THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE
SPELL. EVERY YEAR MORE THAN
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION PLASTIC
BOTTLES ARE THROWN INTO THE
LANDFILL OR LATER IN CALIFORNIA
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BOTTLES ARE
RESOURCE INTENSIVE TO
MANUFACTURE FILL AND SHIP AROUND
THE GLOBE. EACH ONE COMES WITH A
HEFTY CARBON FOOTPRINT BESIDES
RE USE AND RECYCLING WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO REUSE OUR- REDUCE OUR
SINGLE USE PLASTIC WATER
BOTTLES. THE EASIEST WAY TO
ENSURE THAT SINGLE USE PLASTIC
WATER BOTTLES DON'T END UP
SITTING IN A LANDFILL OR
FLOATING IN OUR WATERSHEDS. AND
OCEANS IS TO AVOID THEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE THE AVERAGE CONSUMER
DRINKS AROUND SIXTY FOUR OUNCES
OF WATER PER DAY WHICH CAN
AMOUNT TO APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BOTTLES PER
YEAR. BY SWITCHING TO JUST ONE
REUSABLE WATER BOTTLE FOR THE
YEAR CONSUMERS CAN GREATLY
REDUCED ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT
. CONSUMERS KNOW THIS AS WELL
60% OF ADULTS THE UNITED STATES
ALREADY OPT FOR REUSABLE WATER
BOTTLE. WHAT'S LEFT IS CREATING
ACCESSIBLE AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THIS PRACTICE OF FOR USE
WITH WHICH AB NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE WILL DO. THIS BILL
REQUIRES PUBLICLY ACCESSED X.
AREAS SUCH AS TRANSIT HUBS AND
PUBLIC BUILDINGS TO HAVE
ACCESSIBLE REFILLABLE WATER
BOTTLE STATIONS. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE CLEAN WATER ACCESS EASIER
OR REDUCING THE DEMAND FOR
SINGLE USE PLASTIC. WATER
BOTTLES THANK YOU KNOW RESPECT
LAST YEAR ABOUT. ALL RIGHTS ARE
HEARING HERE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OF WE HAVE RACHEL- LOBBY BELLOWS
THE FIVE GYRES OF- WOULD YOU-
RACHEL WOULD YOU PLEASE BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND JUST TAKE
YOURSELF OFF MUTE AND- PLEASE
TESTIFY. WE DO NOT HAVE RACHEL
ON THE LINE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT- IN THAT CASE IF SHE COMES
ON LATER WILL HAVE HER TESTIFY-
IS THERE ANYONE NOT TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION AS A PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESS. ALL RIGHT
YOU SEEN NO ONE IS PRIMARY
OPPOSITION THEN I'LL ASK OUR
FIRST ANY SUPPORTERS IN THIS
ROOM TO COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE AND- ADJUSTED SO IT
SAID EUROPRIDE HEIGHT. AND
TESTIFY. AND NO ONE'S COMING
FORWARD ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. SO NOW WILL GO TO
PHONE LINES. AND WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND ANYONE
WHO WAS SUPPOSED FOR SUPPORT AND
BUT WE WANT TO HEAR IS YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE AND PLEASE JUST KEEP IT
TO THAT- CHAU OUR TELEPHONE
OPERATOR CAN YOU GET TO HAVE
PEOPLE ON THE LINE. GET THIS IS
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN- AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE ONLY GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. IT WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT WHILE WE ATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS.
NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHEN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICHOLA CARE
AND ON BEHALF OF THE THIRD
BETTER FOUNDATION JOHN THE COURT
OF EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MOMENT WELL TOGETHER FOR THE
FIRST. NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JUST
ON THE LINE HERE ON THE HOPPER
THREE ORGANIZATIONS HEAL THE BAY
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GROUP.
ALSO THE US GREEN BUILDING
COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES WHO
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE YEARS AGO
AND- IN THE ABSENCE OF RACHEL
WANTED TO SAY THAT THE TEAM SEES
THE LOBBY COALITION AS A
COALITION IS A PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE. AND WE OFFER
OUR FULL SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL
VOTE THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. FOUR AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE. ALL RIGHT
JUST A SECOND I'M GOING TO CHECK
ON SOMETHING WITH STAFF.
OPPOSITION INDEED FROM THE
BUILDING OPERATORS. EXCEPT FOR
THE TEN MINUTES. OF OPPOSITION
THEY WERE ASKING FOR. RIGHT
RIGHT RIGHT YEAH. SO AND- IT YOU
LOOK AT THE- THE DENTIST TELL.
YOU TAKE A. FOR THE QUARTER BUT
WE HAVE ANOTHER SO. THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS CHASING SMITH
FROM HALF OF THE NAY STIR
BACKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE STILL
ONLY HAVE FOUR MEMBERS. BUT LET
SARAH. SO MISTER MATHIS MS
GARCIA MISTER SMITH. MISTER
SMITH QUESTION FOR BECAUSE IF
YOU GOT A COUPLE EXEMPTIONS IN
HERE RESIDENTS IN SCHOOLS BUT IT
SAYS STORES BUT THE STORES
EXEMPTED BUT ITS SAYS MALLS THAT
HAVE TO HAVE ONE SO DESERVE
EVERY STORE HAS TOURED DAY
DISRUPTED BY THE MALL HAS TO.
CLARIFICATION ON THAT AT THE
MALL HAS TO BUT NOT EACH STORE
OKAY AND THEN. IF THE ROCK JUST
INSTALLED A DRINKING FOUNTAIN
THEY WOULD HAVE TO REMOVE THAT
AND PUT IN A BOTTLE FILLING
STATION. NOW THIS IS PUT TO WORK
COMPLEMENTARY WITH EXISTING
WATER FOUNTAINS OKAY AND THEN.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE COST IS FOR
IT RANKINGS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
TWO WITH TWELVE HUNDRED
SOMEWHERE IN THER. AND THE
RESEARCH I DID BETWEEN FOUR
THOUSAND AND FORTY FIVE HUNDRED.
AND THEN THE MAINTENANCE HAS
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED BECAUSE YOU
GOTTA CLEAN IT BILL FILTERS
ANNUALLY EVERY YEAR FOR THE F.
AND IF IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
LABOR TO HAVE IT INSTALLED THE
RESEARCH THAT I HAVE IS BET THAT
ITS BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED TO
TWELVE HUNDRED SO MAYBE WE CAN
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT IF IT. COULD
BE HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
INFORMATION YOU HAPPEN
INFORMATION I HAVE IS IT'S FIVE
HUNDRED TO TWELVE HUNDRED SEVEN
COLLECTED A DID WELL I RENDON
VICTOR VALLEY BICYCLE TOOL SO WE
INSTALLED THOSE. ALONG THE ROUTE
AND THERE WAS ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE TIME WE GOT
THE LABOR NET NET INCOME TO MAKE
THIS PART SO. CLOSER HOME COUPLE
BIG CONCERN TO HELP WITH ALL
RIGHT. YOU MAY BE. NOT COMPARING
THIS THING YES. BUT TO. THE OF
THING IS IN THE MOST REQUIRE. IF
IT HAS A PUBLIC. AND THERE ARE
SOME. FOR YOU DRIVE FROM START
STORE. SO THERE ISN'T
NECESSARILY A PUBLIC SPACE TO
PUT IT IN. SO THERE IS THAT
EXCEPTION. JUST IMPLIED WITHIN
THE BELL- IN TERMS OF THE COST
YOU MAY BE KEPT COMPARING APPLES
AND ORANGES. THE TWO OF YOU MAY
BE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT THINGS
WILL HAVE TO SORT THAT OUT
LATER- ANYONE ELSE HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT. WELL WE
WILL GET A MOTION AND A SECOND
VOTE WELL WE GET ONE MORE PERSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
- I SHOULD HAVE ASKED YOU IF YOU
WANT TO CLOSE. AT JUST WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. HAHA WE
NOW HAVE FIVE WAIT. WE'RE GOING
TO GET YOUR VOTE YES. ALL RIGHT
- WE HAVE FIVE SO- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR
SECRETARY THE CORK CARE. SMITH
HERE ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN MATHIS
MURATSUCHI WALDRON. WE HAVE FIVE
OKAY AND- WE'LL TAKE A VOTE
FIRST- CIRCLE ON THIS BILL AND
THEN MOVE. DO WE HAVE A SECOND
MISTER MURATSUCHI. YEAH I THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT CAN I MAKE SURE
WHICH BILL WE'RE LOOKING- SO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. AND
SO NOW WE WILL LAW CALL THE ROLL
ON THIS VOTE AND THEN WILL BE
DOING THE CONSENT CALENDAR- I'M
SICK MR SECRETARY. ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
MAIENSCHEIN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER YOUR REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CORK HI. BURKE
ICE. SMITH NOW A REGULAR. MARKET
HAN. CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA HI HOLDEN. MATHIS MATHIS
NOT VOTING. MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE WALDRON. SO IT'S
THREE EYES AND NO AND NOT VOTING
AND SEVERAL MORE PEOPLE TO
VIOLATE OUR STRUCTURE. THANK YOU
. SECOND GOOD MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY EIGHT
EDUARDO GARCIA DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE AND ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY TWO CHEN DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CORK BY CORK II
SMITH SMITHII ARAMBULA PARA QUE
HAN. CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA HI HOLDEN. MATHIS MATHIS
II MERE THIRTY MINUTES TO GI
WALDRON. THAT HAS FIVE.
EXCELLENT MR GARCIA PLEASE COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES. TODAY I PRESENT
TO YOU AB TWENTY SIX OH ONE A
BILL THAT WOULD PROHIBIT THE
ISSUANCE OF A WASTEWATER
DISCHARGE PERMIT FOR A NEW
LANDFILL WAIT LATERAL EXPANSION
OF ANY EXISTING AND FILL THAT IS
USED FOR THE DISPOSAL OF NON
HAZARDOUS SOLID WASTE IF THE
LAND IS LOCATED WITHIN THE
VICINITY OF THE U. S. MEXICO
BORDER. THIS BILLS ATTEMPTING TO
HELP CURB THE AMOUNT OF
EMISSIONS AND AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS THAT HARM THE HEALTH OF
OUR BORDER COMMUNITIES WHY NOT
ASK AND- I APOLOGIZE MISS IRWIN
WAS NEXT IF YOU DON'T MIND WILL
HEAR MR GARCIA. I JUST DIDN'T
SEE YOU. WHICH IS RIDICULOUS BUT
SOMETIMES WE ALL MAKE MISTAKES.
A GUY HAD MISTRIAL BE EVEN.
SHORTER OUR GOAL HERE IS TO.
ADDRESS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUES THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE IN PLAGUE IN THE- ORDER
COMMUNITIES OF CALIFORNIA- THE
U. S. MEXICO BORDER. WITH ME IS
MY BE CAST A DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR THE OFFICE OF VICE CHAIR
NORA VARGAS COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
FOR SAN DIEGO WHO IS HERE TO
TESTIFY ON THIS BILL. HI
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY VICE
CHAIR NORA VARGAS IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX OH ONE. AB TWENTY
SIX A ONE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OF MANY RESIDENTS
IN SANTA COUNTY ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO LIVE IN BY STROKES IS
DISTRICT NEAR THE US BORDER WITH
MEXICO. OUR FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES NEAR THE BORDER FACE
MANY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUES- THAT INCLUDE POOR AIR
QUALITY AND LACK OF GREEN OPEN
SPACE. LANDFILLS ARE AMONG
SOCIETY'S MOST IMPACTFUL LAND
USES AND NUMEROUS LAWS ARE IN
PLACE RESTRICTING THEIR CITING
TO SAFE DISTANCES FROM HOMES
SCHOOLS AND OTHER SENSITIVE
AREAS. HOWEVER STATE LAW DOES
NOT CURRENTLY ADDRESSED THE
IMPACT OF LOCAL. OF LOCATING
PROPOSED LANDFILLS AND
COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN YOU'RE
THE U. S. MEXICO BORDER. OUR
BORDER AREA WAS RECENTLY RATED
NINETY OUT OF ONE HUNDRED ON THE
LATEST CALAVERAS SCREEN MAKING
IT ONE OF THE MOST POLLUTED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT SURPRISINGLY OUR
BORDERS PREDOMINANTLY LATINO
WORKING FAMILIES AND
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED. THE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IDOLING OF
VEHICLES INCLUDING BUT IN IN THE
CROSSLAND PORTS OF ENTRY. I'M
THE PRESENT HUGE CHALLENGE TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND LOCAL AIR
QUALITY AS A RESULT IT'S
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND MORALLY
WRONG TO PLACE OUR MOST
POLLUTING LAND USES IN THESE
COMMUNITIES. AB TWENTY SIX OH
ONE WILL PROTECT OUR BORDER
COMMUNITIES FROM BEING FURTHER
FOR IN WITH AIR POLLUTION MORE
GROUND ARE PER WATER POLLUTION
AND MORE TRUCK TRAFFIC. IT WILL
ALSO HELP ENSURE THE TROUBLE BE
CUENTA RIVER VALLEY IS NOT
FURTHER POLLUTED BEYOND CURRENT
LEVELS. AND IS CONSISTENT WITH
OUR COUNTIES CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
ON BEHALF OF VICE CHAIR MARKETS
I WANT TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL. IT'S TIME THE STATE
LAW PROTECT THESE BORDER
COMMUNITIES FROM THE IMPACTS OF
LANDFILLS IN THE SAME WAY THAT
IT DES FOR SCHOOLS ANOTHER
SENSITIVE LAND USES. FURTHERMORE
AB TWENTY SIX A ONE ALSO HAS
ECONOMIC BENEFITS. I UNDERSTAND
YOU WOULD BE PART OF A NATIONAL
REGION CURRENTLY FUELS A TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY BILLION CROSS
BORDER ECONOMY. AND SOFOR THE
REASONS ARE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CLIMATE ACTION AND OUR
CROSS BORDER ECONOMY. WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY SIX A ONE THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD ARM. I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. I KNOW IT'S
REGISTERED FOR THAT SO- WHAT
I'LL DO NOW IS ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO IS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD. ALEXA CHÁVEZ OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
. OKAY ARE NOW WILL GO TO PHONE
LINES- AND WE'LL HEAR FROM
ANYONE WHO HAS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AGAIN THIS IS ONLY ON
AB TWENTY SIX OH ONE GARCIA. AND
IT IS- YOU'LL PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY IN
YOUR POSITION- MADAM PHONE
OPERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX OH
ONE. FOR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY SIX OH ONE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER
THE LINE NUMBER.
AND MINE NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE YOU
MAY BE LISTED AS MINE EIGHTY
THREE. WHERE SHALL LEVY BALANCE
BUT THE FIVE GYRES INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX OH ONE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE FOR AB
TWENTY SIX OH ONE ALL RIGHT-
FIRST STEP- QUESTIONS THEN OR
COMMENTS FROM THE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'LL JUST MAKE A
COMMENT WHICH IS- I THINK IT'S
GOOD TO KEEP WHAT COULD BE A
CONTROVERSIAL FACILITY AWAY FROM
THE MEXICAN BORDER- JUST MAKES
THINGS THAT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
AND SO I THINK THIS IS A
WORTHWHILE BILL MR GARCIA WOULD
YOU BUT SEE CAN WE HAVE A MOTION
ARE WE'VE HAD A- AS WE HAVE THE
MOTION YET NOW. OKAY AND THEN
YOU MAY CLOSE I CONCUR WITH YOUR
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR AND I
WOULD SAY IN THE CON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR YOU APPROVED ANOTHER
BILL DEALING WITH BORDER REGION
POLLUTION TIJUANA NEW RIVER HI
AND SO- IT IT CLEARLY MAKES
SENSE THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT OUR
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE
WHO CROSSED THE BORDER ON A
REGULAR BASIS- WITH MEXICO AT
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY FOR US IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL ABSOLUTELY AND YOUR
COMMENT ON. OTHER BILLS AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE NEW RIVER-
THE- OTHER POLLUTION COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER A CALIFORNIA
IS GOING TO BE COMBAT GOING TO
BE CAN DONATE MONEY TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THE SICK
SO. MISTER ROSS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWENTY SIX OH ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES. CORK HI
GREGORY SMITH. SMITH NOW A
REGULAR OUR QUE HAN CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI HOLDEN
. MATHIS OKAY MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I WALDRON. CURRENTLY
AT THREE OKAY WE HAVE THREE AND-
IT'S JUST A BUSY DAY WITH PEOPLE
PRESENTING ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO
WELL WE'LL GET WE'LL GET
EVERYBODY HERE EVENTUALLY. OUR
JUST EVEN BEFORE YOU START
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. WE'VE
HAVE OTHER BILLS ON BATTERY
RECYCLING BEFORE I THINK THIS IS
THE BEST VERSION WE'VE EVER SEEN
I GUESS I'M LETTING PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT I THINK YOUR BELT AND YOU
OF WORK BETTER WITH- ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND- LET ME SAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH DOCTOR QUIRK FOR THAT AND I
HAVE TO SAY WE- HAVE EXCELLENT
STAFF ALLEN OF THEY HAVE WORKED
THEY THEY HAVE. HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE THIS IS A
VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE BUT WE DO
NEED TO. RESOLVE THAT. SO AB AT
TWENTY FOUR FORTY WOULD CREATE A
SAFE ACCESSIBLE SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO DROP OFF
BATTERIES FOR PROPER DISPOSAL.
BATTERIES ARE BECOMING MORE
PREVALENT IN OUR EVERYDAY LIVES
AND THE LACK OF CONVENIENT
DISPOSAL OPTIONS IS LEADING TO
HIGHER LEVELS OF TOXIC BATTERIES
ENTERING INTO OUR WASTE STREAM.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY EIGHT TEEN
SURVEY OF TWENTY SIX OF
CALIFORNIA MARCH TWENTY
FACILITIES EXPERIENCED AT LEAST
ONE FIRE DURING THE PRIOR TWO
YEARS. AND BATTERIES BECAUSE 65%
OF THOSE FIRES WE MUST DO BETTER
WITHOUT DRAMATICALLY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF BATTERIES ENTERING
CALIFORNIA'S WAY STREAM WE CAN
UNDOUBTEDLY SUFFER ADDITIONAL
FIRES THAT COULD RESULT IN THE
LOSS OF LIVES AND PROPERTY. AND-
JEOPARDIZE CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE I WANT
TO THANK AGAIN THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR WORK ON
THE BILL. AND EMPHASIZE MY
COMMITMENT TO FINDING SOLUTIONS
AND ALLEVIATING CONCERNS. AND
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE-
KAYLA ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE AND CHASE AND
SMELTER ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STILL STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. VERY WELL WOULD LIKE TO
GO FIRST. OKAY HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN ROB ON
THE OF READ WASTE WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY BASED IN
SAN MATEO COUNTY- THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO APPROXIMATELY. FORTY
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND RESIDENCES AND ELEVEN
THOUSAND BUSINESSES. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE EXPERIENCED FIRST
HAND THE CATASTROPHIC EFFECTS OF
A LITHIUM ION BATTERY INDUCED
FIRE AT A RECYCLING CENTER. THEY
COMPLETELY DEVASTATED OUR
FACILITY SHUTTING US DOWN FOR
NINETY DAYS AND CAUSING EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES IT TOOK APPROXIMATELY A
YEAR TO FULLY REPAIR EVERYTHING.
PRIOR TO THE FIRE WE HAD JUST
ONE SHERMAN SOME PROVIDER NOW WE
NEED SEVEN TO PROVIDE THE SAME
KIND OF COVERAGE. INSURANCE
PROVIDERS ARE FINDING IT TOO
RISKY TO COVER FACILITIES LIKE
OURS AFTER THE EXCESSIVE DAMAGES
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES TO REMOVE BATTERIES
FROM ARE WE STREAM BUT LAST YEAR
ALONE WE SUFFERED TWELVE FIRES
BETWEEN OUR MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITY AND TRANSFER STATION.
TEN OF THEM COULD BE ATTRIBUTED
TO LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. ANYONE
OF THESE FIRES COULD GROW INTO A
FIRE LIKE THE ONE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND ANOTHER MAJOR FIRE
COULD CAUSE US TO LOSE OUR
INTERNS COMPLETELY. FURTHERMORE
THESE BATTERIES THREATEN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR PUBLICLY FUNDED
WASTE COLLECTION AND RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INSPIRES POSE
A SAFETY HAZARD TO OUR WORKERS.
THIS ISSUE IS COMMON AT MARKS
ACROSS THE NATION THIS IS A
CRISIS THAT NEEDS A SOLUTION NOW
AS LOOKING MINE BATTERIES ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE COMMON
EVERYDAY PRODUCTS. AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY IS CRITICAL TO
DIVERTING BATTERIES AND PRODUCTS
IN THE WASTE STREAM TO PROTECT
OUR WORKERS OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OUR ENVIRONMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY OR DRIVE UP. THANK
YOU. MISTER SMELSER. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S GOOD TO
BE HERE WITH YOU- IN PERSON
AGAIN. ADJACENT SPONSOR SHAGARI
ATTRITIONAL THROUGH AND LAYING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL A CO
SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE BUT ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL
ALAMEDA. COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY OR STOP WASTE AND THE
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY SO. KILL SPOKE ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR FORTY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF TAXPAYER TAXPAYER
FUNDED SOLID WASTE AND RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE I'M GONNA FOCUS
ON WHAT THE BILL. DOES KIND OF
MECHANICALLY. AT FIRST I WANNA
BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH DEMONIZING
SPECIFIC PRODUCTS THAT'S NOT
WHAT IT'S ABOUT AT ALL- IT'S
SIMPLY A RECOGNITION THAT SOME
PRODUCTS HAVE UNIQUE IMPACTS-
AND PRODUCERS- SHOULD THEREFORE
SHARING THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COLLECTION AND RECYCLING. SO
IT'S NOT ABOUT DEMONISATION IT'S
JUST ABOUT COLLABORATION AND
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY. AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY REQUIRES PRODUCERS OF
LOOSE BATTERIES. AND BATTERY
<c.blue>MBEDDED PRODUCTS TO ESTABLISH-</c>
AN EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM FOR THEIR
PRODUCTS. HIGHER VERSIONS OF
THIS BILL. HAD BOTH PRODUCT
CATEGORIES IN ONE PROGRAM THIS
BILL SPLITS THEM SEPARATELY SO
THE- MANUFACTURERS CAN RUN THEIR
OWN INDEPENDENT PROGRAMS- MORE
SUITED TO THE SPECIFIC PRODUCTS.
SIMILAR TO THE PHARMACEUTICAL
BILL- WHEN IT DID SHARP SINBAD'S
SEPARATELY- THE STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED BY TWENTY TO
FOUR FORTY IS STRUCTURALLY
CONSISTENT WITH RECENTLY PASSED
YOUR CHIP PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN SEEN IN THIS COMMITTEE
AGAIN SB TWO ONE TWO. IS THE
MOST RECENT VERSION THE BILL
DOES SEVERAL THINGS AT REQUIRES
PRODUCERS TO DESIGN FUND AND
IMPLEMENT A TAKE BACK AND
RECYCLING PROGRAM FOR THEIR
PRODUCTS- IT CONTAINS A PLAN
APPROVAL PROCESS THAT PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT THE GIVES PRODUCERS
THE FREEDOM TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM
THAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM. IT'S A
PERFORMANCE BASED METRICS AS
OPPOSED TO A COMMAND CONTROL
REGULATION. SEES ME. IT
ESTABLISHES MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE COLLECTION NETWORK THAT
CREATES AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE SO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS CAN HAVE A
VOICE IN THE PROCESS- ANY
CREATES AN OBLIGATION ON SOME
RETAILERS BUT NOT ALL. A TO
COLLECT LOOSE BATTERIES- AND
SOME- BATTERY AND BETTER
PRODUCTS. AND FINALLY IT
ESTABLISHES STRONG OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS- I ALSO
WANT TO THINK- THE DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE WORKING
CONSTRUCTIVELY ON AB. TWENTY
FOUR FORTY SOME OF WHOM WERE
PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED BY THE
CONVERSATION THIS YEAR. HAS BEEN
VERY PRODUCTIVE AND WE'RE
ENCOURAGED BY THE DISCUSSIONS-
AND THEN FINALLY AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS USUALLY SOME OF THE
DETAILS OF TWENTY FOUR FORTY
WILL CONTINUE TO CHANGE YOU MAY
NOTICE A FEW BLANKS IN THE BILL-
WERE ATTEMPTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND
COME TO AGREEMENT BEFORE WE FILL
IN SOME OF THOSE DETAILS. THAT'S
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE- AND CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. A COLD FRONT TO DO
SO. VERY GOOD- WE HAVE. A
PRIMARY. OPPOSITION WITNESS FOR
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY- AND I
BELIEVE HE IS ON THE LINE WALTER
ALL POWER AND VICE PRESIDENTIAL
VICE PRESIDENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
AFFAIRS AND INDUSTRY
SUSTAINABILITY I DON'T HAVE MY
NOTES WHAT THE ORGANIZATION IS
SIMPLY STATE THAT- SO MISTER A
ALCORN YOU SHOULD BE LIVE ON THE
LINE AND IF YOU WANT MEET
YOURSELF WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HEAR YOU. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES WE HEAR YOU FINE. OKAY
THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU ALSO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN- I AM
WALTER ALCORN ON THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS OF CONSUMER
ELECTRONICS. WHICH ACTUALLY
INCLUDE BATTERIES AND HAVE BEEN
BATTERED BATTERIES- SIXTY EIGHT
PROBABLY BEST KNOWN FOR THE
PRODUCE AT THE PRODUCER OF
STEVIA THE CONSUMER ELECTRONICS
SHOW. IN LAS VEGAS EVERY YEAR
AND- WITH THAT- BUT THAT EVENT
WHAT THE LARGEST TRADE SHOW IN
THE COUNTRY AND THE WE HAVE. AN
EVENT WHERE MANY INNOVATORS HAVE
PRODUCED PRODUCTS USED IN OUR
HOMES FOR THE FIRST TIME- WE SEE
A LOT OF INNOVATION THERE. MY
COMMENTS ARE GONNA FOCUS ON
BATTERY INVENTED PRODUCTS- ONE
OF THE THINGS WE LEARNED-
SPECIFICALLY ON BATTERY
COLLECTION PROGRAMS- THE BEST-
MOST IMPORTANT PROGRAM ELEMENT
FOR DIVERTING BATTERIES TO
PROPER RECYCLING IS BETTER
PUBLIC EDUCATION- SO WE'RE
REALLY NOT ADDRESSING. BATTERY
PORTIONS OF THE BILL. ALTHOUGH I
DO APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
DETAILS ARE STILL BEING WORKED
OUT THERE TO. PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE WITH BATTERY IN PLAN AS
THEY VERY NEEDS THAN BLUE
SPATTER. THAT NEED TO BE CALLED-
FIRST. BATTERIES ARE IN THEY'RE
INVISIBLE TO CONSUMERS AND
THEREFORE- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
COLLECTION SYSTEM THAT WILL NOT
BE INTUITIVE BUT TO CONSUMERS
THERE ARE A LOT OF PRODUCTS THAT
HAVE BEEN BETTER BATTERIES. THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN BETTER BATTERIES
OR MAY NOT YOU KNOW LIKE
HEADPHONES OR EAR BUDS
SMARTPHONE CASES PORTABLE
PRINTERS WATCHES- LOTS OF SMALL
APPLIANCES. THERE REALLY IS-
IT'S REALLY A MODEL BY MODEL IN
SOME CASES DETERMINATION WHETHER
OR NOT THERE'S A BATTERY IN
BETTER THAN US AND WE WERE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THE WAY THIS IS
STRUCTURED THAT WOULD NOT BE
INTO TO CONSUMERS AND RETAILERS.
AND OTHERS ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM THE OTHER CONCERN WE
HAVE IS ON THE PRE APPROVED TO
SELL PROVISIONS- BASICALLY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ONLY THAT
PRODUCTS ARE MENTIONED BUT ALSO.
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING FROM CAR
KEYLESS ENTRY REMOTES TO
PORTABLE GLUCOSE READERS AND
SMOKE ALARMS YOU KNOW THEY ALL
INVOLVE HAVING BETTER BATTERIES
AND THE CURRENTLY ON THE MARKET
AND THEY'RE GONNA BE FUTURE
INNOVATIONS THAT COME TO SO. OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT INSTEAD
OF DEALING WITH THE IMPACT OF
THE BATTERY BETTER PRODUCTS THE
SAME WAY AS LOOSE BATTERIES.
EXPAND I THINK OUR COME ELECTRON
WASTE PRO. WITH THE- CONSUMER
FOR. TO COVER THE PRODUCT THAT.
IN BETTER BATTERIES AND LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE. WITH A SPONSOR
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE.
WE CAN- WORK IN THAT DIRECTION
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR VERY CLEAR
TESTIMONY- SO NOW WE WILL GO TO-
YES WELL ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
IS IN SUPPORT. HI MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AT BETWEEN YOUR POSITION
HERE FIELDING GRIEVES OF VIACOM
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT A LARGE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL
ADDRESSING CLASS TO CLASS THREE
MEDICAL DEVICES WERE STILL HAVE
REMAINING TECHNICAL CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF APPLICATION
FOR CLASS ONE MEDICAL DEVICES.
BUT WORKING VERY CONSTRUCTIVELY
WITH THE AUTHORED SPONSORS
APPRECIATE THEIR COLLABORATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
PERSEPHONE MORE ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY BY A COMMON LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AUTHORED
HER STOCK IN THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON ALEXA
CHÁVEZ WITH CALIFORNIA AGAINST
WASTE WERE PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
MEMBER DINNER FEEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION FOR THE REASONS
STATED OUR LETTER WE ARE OPPOSED
REALLY APPRECIATE THE OFFER
REACHING OUT TO US EARLY IN THE
PROCESS LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU-
VERY GOOD OF SO WE'VE HEARD FROM
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY. FOR
AGAINST OR IN BETWEEN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR HALF
OF P. R. B. A. THEIR CHARGEABLE
BATTERY ASSOCIATION HIM EMAIL
THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION I
SHARE YOUR SENTIMENTS- FROM
EARLIER I'VE WORKED ON BATTERY
BILLS FOR A LONG TIME NOW AND
THIS IS CERTAINLY THE MOST
PROMISING START WE WILL BE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL. COMMENTS
TO THE PROPONENTS WITH A
DISCREPANCY WITH THEM ANY
PARTICULAR I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THE EASE OF THE PROGRAM THIS
BILL HAD NEVER SEEN THAT IN A
BATTERY BILL BEFORE AS WELL AS
THE FACT THAT IT CORRECTLY
CAPTURES PRODUCTS THAT ARE SOLD
WITH BATTERIES- WHICH WE-
APPRECIATE. SO THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD- ARM VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY OF EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM. PART WILL NOW GO TO- THE
PHONE LINES. AND AGAIN THIS IS
FOR A. B. TWO FOUR FOUR ZERO- R.
AND- WE JUST WANT ANYONE WHO
SPEAKS TO ONLY SPEAK TO THAT
GIVE ME THEIR GIVE US THEIR
NAME- ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
POSITION- PATTOM PHONE OPERATOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DOCUMENT CAPITAL PAYMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
CLUB SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN- WE DO HAVE
SORENSON LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE OFFICE THANK YOU. NINE
ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I TERRON MEMBERS THIS IS
SCHERING GREEN WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT HERE IN SUPPORT. MY
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED MEMBERS ADAM ADAM HAPPY
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO REGISTRY CLEANER CONDITION
BUT WANT TO TAKE UP TO THANK THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR FOR
ENGAGEMENT THIS YEAR ON THE
BILL- OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN GET
THERE. THANK YOU. NINE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JACOB CASKEY ON BEHALF
THE ASSOCIATION OF HOME
APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS WE ARE
CLOSED DUE TO THE- INCLUSION OF
INDEBTED BATTERY PRODUCTS. NINE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THOMAS
GARDNER WITH THE BALKAN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT THE CITY
RESULT IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AARON RATE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE TOY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
OH TWO YOU MAY BE A NEW THERE
YOU ARE. MANDIRI PURCELL WITH
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR CHEMICAL
AND TOXIC EIGHTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS ON AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
. ARE VERY WELL. SO AT THIS
POINT I'D LIKE TO MOVE THIS BILL
AND I WOULD ASK THE VICE CHAIR
OF HE MIGHT GIVE ME A COURTESY
SECOND. YES BUT I DO HAVE A ONE
QUESTION OR JUST A CALL YOU CAN
HAVE ALL THE QUESTIONS YOU WANT
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO VOTE FOR
JUST A MINUTE JACKSON'S. DOING
ANYTHING. THANK YOU WE'RE WE'RE
A LITTLE. SHORT ON THE MODEL NOW
SO. IN JUST JUST AWARENESS OF
THE BATTERIES WERE START WITH
YOUR BILL HERE. GOING INTO THE
FUTURE WITH A LITHIUM BATTERY
FOR THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE READY TO. DO
SOMETHING WITH THESE RECYCLE
BATTERIES. WE ALL HEARD ABOUT
THE SHIP THE BURNED UP WITH A
THOUSAND CARS AND- BECAUSE A
LITHIUM BATTERIES. BUT THE START
THAT CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD
. THIS IS. THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY
NOT PART OF A NUMBER OF THIS
WITH PROGRAM BUT IT IT IS
CERTAINLY A BIG CONVERSATION WE
DO NEED TO KNOW HOW WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO DISPOSE OF THOSE- CAR
BATTERIES. OBVIOUSLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
RECYCLED. AND BUT IT'S JUST NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE FOCUSING
ON. HAVE RIGHT NOW I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE THAT COMMENT WITH THAT
STUFF. LIKE TO START THE SECOND
I WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORTER
RIGHT NOW BUT I LOOK FOR THE
CONVERSATION APPRECIATE THAT. I
HAVE A QUESTION AND I APOLOGIZE
IF THIS STARTED ADDRESSED
RUNNING FROM ONE COMMITTEE
HEARING TO ANOTHER DIFFERENT
BUILDINGS- BUT I KNOW THAT THE
PREDECESSOR BILL HAD AN
EXEMPTION FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
THOSE WITH GROSS RECEIPTS OVER
MILLION DOLLARS HAVING TO DO
THESE TORTURE PROGRAMS. AND I
THINK THAT'S IN THE BILL NOW BUT
IS THIS SOMETHING YOU'RE
CONSIDERING. THERE THERE IS A
FOR COLLECTION SITES YES AN
EXEMPTION FOR. IT IS THE ID
NUMBER FIVE YEAH IT'S FIVE ONE
MILLIONS OF UNDER FIVE LOCATIONS
YET AND STATE OKAY THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD- YOU MAY CLOSE ALL
RIGHT AND I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
JUST QUICKLY SOME OF THE ISSUES
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS OBVIOUSLY
THE WHAT WE HAVE FOR RECYCLING
RIGHT NOW IS A BATTERY RECYCLING
IS NOT SUFFICIENT AND THIS IS A
CRUCIAL ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT YOU KNOW THERE THERE ARE
IT'S TWO SEPARATE IF YOU ARE
PROGRAM SO YOU HEARD A LOT OF
THE- OPPOSITION MENTIONED THE
CONCERN ABOUT EMBEDDED BATTERIES
BUT THEY ALMOST WENT ALONG THEIR
OWN ARGUMENT WHEN THEY STARTED
ALONG THE LIST OF WELDERS
CELLPHONES AND THERE'S WATCHES
AND THERE'S THIS AND THERE'S
THAT AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM SO IT IS. REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE DEAL WITH NOT
ONLY THE EMBEDDED ISSUE WHICH
WILL BE SEPARATE FROM THE LOOSE
BATTERIES AND I WOULD I WOULD
LIKE TO MISTER SMELLS ARE TO SEE
IF HE HAS ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD
ON TO THAT BUT I JUST I JUST
WANT TO SAY NO EVEN I GUESS GOOD
MISTER GOVERNOR AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SOMEBODY THAT
HAS IT. FOUR YEARS WE ARE REALLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH EVERY
SINGLE STAKEHOLDER AND- I HEARD.
ONE OF THE- ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
TALK ABOUT EDUCATION. EDUCATION
IS THE BOTTOM LINE THE MOST THE
MOST CRITICAL PART OF IT WE
CANNOT BE SUCCESSFUL UNTIL
EVERYBODY KNOWS EXACTLY. WHERE
WHEN THEY'RE VAPING PEN IS OF IT
IS IT IS COMPOSED. THE HEAD WE
THAT THAT THAT THEY PUT IT IN A
SAFE SPOT SO IT'S NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE IT CAUSING FIRES IN OUR
RECYCLING. FACILITIES AND
POLLUTING OUR ENVIRONMENT SO I
THINK THAT YOU HAD A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ON SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION BEYOND THAT. YEAH I
MEAN I WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST
OBSERVE I THINK- HISTORICALLY
THESE PROGRAMS WORK BEST- WHEN
THERE'S A NEGOTIATED COMPROMISE
IN THE GUEST BE TWO ONE TWO
AGAIN TO GO BACK. THAT IS REALLY
MAYBE THAT'S- WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO FOLLOW THAT SAME. PATH HERE
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH FOLKS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOR THE FOLKS WHO ARE
OPPOSE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
BUY INTO- SO THAT'S CERTAINLY
OUR GOAL WILL CONTINUE DOWN THAT
PATH. YES SO THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AND THE- WOULD
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
WELL IF ANYONE CAN DO IT YOU AND
I. REALLY HOPE THAT THAT WILL
MAKE IT THIS TIME. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
NUMBER TWO AB TWO FOUR. IRWIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES. WORK HIGH.
COURT HI SMITH. SMITH NO
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BURKE AND I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI HOLDEN. MATHIS HOW DOES NOT
VOTING MURATSUCHI WALDRON. WILL
EVENTUALLY GET ENOUGH PEOPLE
THAT ARE TO PASS THEY'LL- THANK
YOU AT THE MOMENT THEN I'D LIKE
TO BRING UP MISS FRIEDMAN. AND
I'D LIKE I HAVE GOING TO HAVE TO
LEAVE TO ADD ON AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. ARM AND SO WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS MAKE A MOTION AND JUST
IN CASE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE LATER ON COULD I HAVE A
SECOND. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. SO
MOTION AND A SECOND. MISTER VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND OF
COURSE I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU-
QUIRK AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE WOULD
PROHIBIT THE INCLUSION OF P.
FOSS CHEMICALS IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS SO THOSE ARE THINGS
LIKE LIPSTICK AND FACE CREAM AND
OTHER THINGS THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE THIS IN THE CLASS OF
CHEMICALS KNOWN AS OUR I CAN'T
PRONOUNCE IT. THE P. FOSS ARE A
LARGE FAMILY OF CHEMICALS KNOWN
FOR THEIR LONG LASTING WATER AND
OIL RESISTANT AND TEMPERATURE
RETAINING PROPERTIES HOWEVER
THESE PRODUCTS SHED P. PASSED
CHEMICALS OVERTIME AND EXPOSE
PEOPLE O THE CHEMICALS. PFOS
CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
HAVE ADVERSE IMPACTS ON HUMAN
HEALTH INCLUDING ON CHILDREN AND
IS SOMEONE WHOSE EIGHT YEAR OLD
IS GETTING INTO HER MAKE UP
PRETTY MUCH ON A DAILY BASIS IT
IS A CONCERN TO ME PERSONALLY.
RECENT TESTING SHOWS THAT
MANUFACTURERS INTENTIONALLY ADD
P. FOSTER PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
SUCH AS LIPSTICK MASCARA AND
SHAVING CREAM SO YOU MEN ARE NOT
IMMUNE. SINCE THE P. FAST
CHEMICALS ARE NOT ESSENTIAL FOR
THESE PRODUCTS TO BE USED AN
ALTERNATIVE PRODUCTS WITHOUT P.
FAUCETS ARE AVAILABLE PEOPLE ARE
EXPOSED. LITTLE REASON. A
RESTRICTION ON THE KILLER CARE
AT THE SALE OF PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS CONTAINING P. FOSS. IS
REALLY THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS
TO PRODUCTS THAT DO NOT PRESENT
A HEALTH RISK TO THEIR FAMILIES.
JUST BY THEIR MERE PRSENCE IN
THEIR HOME. AND I WANT TO SAY
THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I DID NOT
INTRODUCED THIS BILL. UNTIL I
FIRST REACHED OUT TO INDUSTRY.
AND ASK THEM IF THEY WOULD BE
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN THE EFFORT
TO BAN P. FAUCETS AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS. AND THEY ARE ALL
CHOSE TO WORK WITH US ON THIS
BILL ONE TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
ONE AND I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
THAT. AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
MEET AND WORK WITH THEM.
REGARDING WE AMEND THIS BILL TO
ALLOW FOR SOME UNINTENTIONAL
CONTAMINATION OF PRODUCTS. THIS
IS A TOUGH ISSUE BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE SUPERIOR IN MANY PRODUCTS.
AT THAT DON'T HAVE P. FAUCETS ON
THE INGREDIENT LABEL. SO EVEN IF
YOU WERE TRYING TO SCREEN THEM
OUT IN YOUR HOME IT WILL BE VERY
VERY HARD TO. AND THEY MIGHT
EVEN HAVE VERY HIGH LEVELS OF
PEOPLE PAST. AND I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THAT AS SOMEONE WHO WAS ON
OF WATER BOARD FOR ALMOST EIGHT
YEARS. FOSSE'S ARE ALSO A REAL
EMERGING. CONTAMINANT OF CONCERN
BECAUSE THE LEECH OFF OF THESE
PRODUCTS WHEN YOU WASH YOUR
FACE. AND GO INTO THE WATER
SUPPLY AND RIGHT NOW THE
EATABLE. I TO GET OUT OF WILL.
AT THEIR- CUSTOMERS AND WHY
DON'T WANT TO BE DRINKING THE
STUFF. AND REALLY WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO GET A HANDLE ON IT.
NOW P. FAUCETS CANNELLA
FUNCTIONALLY FUNCTIONAL USE A
VERY LOW LEVEL SOME COSMETICS.
FOR EXAMPLE THEY CAN BE
INTENTIONALLY ATTITUDE
INGREDIENT- INTO A COSMETIC
THEN. AND THEN THE P. FOSS MY
ONLY JOB IS A VERY TRACE AMOUNT
IN THE OVERALL PRODUCT- THAT
SAID I AM WILLING TO WORK. WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND WITH
MANUFACTURERS TO IDENTIFY A SAFE
BUT REASONABLE AWAY WAY. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THIS UNINTENTIONAL
CROSS CONTAMINATION OF PEOPLE
ASSETS AND PRODUCTS. TESTIFYING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE ISSUES A
LITTLE WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP AT DOCTOR. LYDIA
JOB WITH THE GREEN SCIENCE.
POLICY INSTITUTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR- YOUR PRESENTATION
FOR OUR FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SUSAN LITTLE ON THE
AND I'M WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP A CO SPONSOR OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN ONE. BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
CAL PERGER ALSO CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL. CONCERNS ARE MOUNTING
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD ABOUT THE
TOXICITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSISTENCE AT THE FAST
CHEMICALS THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED IT PLANS TO
PHASE OUT ALL NON ESSENTIAL USES
A P. FAST. AND CALIFORNIA'S YOU
KNOW BECAUSE YOU'VE SEEN THESE
BILLS HAS MOVED FORWARD TO
PROHIBIT THE ENTIRE CLASS OF P.
FAST. FOR MULTIPLE PRODUCTS AND
OUR DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL HAS ALSO TAKEN ACTION ON
THE ENTIRE PATH CLASS OF P. FAST
AND OTHER PRODUCTS LIKE CARPETS-
SO HOW ABOUT P. FAST IN THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE APPLY TO OUR
BODIES EVERY DAY. RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT MANY COSMETICS
CONTAIN P. FAST EVEN WHEN THE P.
FAST IS NOT LISTED ON THE
PRODUCT'S LABEL. BECAUSE WOMEN
AND GIRLS ARE THE PRIMARY. USERS
OF COSMETICS THERE GET GUYS YOU
GUYS USE IT TOO. BUT WOMEN AND
GIRLS WE KNOW EVEN TEENAGE GIRLS
CAN USE AS MANY AS A DOZEN
PRODUCTS EVERY MORNING WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING READY. TO GO TO
SCHOOL. TO GET OUT THE DOOR.
THIRTY FASTER LINK SHOULD LINK
TO A RANGE OF HEALTH EFFECTS
INCLUDING THE DESTRUCTION OF
HORMONES AND HORMONE RESPONSES
TO WOMEN AND GIRLS. BECAUSE
MEDICS WITH P. FAST. COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT THEIR
HEALTH AND THE HEALTH OF THEIR
CHILDREN. PLEASE PROTECT WOMEN
AND CHILDREN FROM THIS DALY AND
UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE TO P. FAST
AND SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- PHONE MODERATOR YOU
CAN DO YOU HAVE A DOCTOR LYDIA
CHAHAL BUT THE GREEN SCIENCE
POLICY INSTITUTE ON THE PHONE
LIKE. AS WE LOOK UP AND REMIND
US OF. THANK YOU HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES. RIGHT ON MY NAME IS
WHAT THE DOCTOR LYDIA DAHLE I
HAVE A PHD IN CHEMISTRY AND I
CURRENTLY WORK WITH THE GREEN
SCIENCE POLICY INSTITUTE WE ARE
A GROUP OF FINE BUT WORK TOWARDS
THE REDUCTION OF HELP COMING
CHEMICALS IN EVERYDAY CONSUMER
PRODUCTS AND THE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE. WHAT
JUNIOR MY INSTITUTE CO AUTHOR TO
PEER REVIEWED PAPER WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF NOTRE DAME THAT
MEASURE TEETH IN CHEMICAL OUR
RESEARCH SHOWED HIGH LEVELS OF
FLOORING WHICH IS THE MARKET
PRETTY FAST IN MORE THAN HALF
OF. HIS THIRTY ONE COSMETIC
PRODUCTS WHEN WE TESTED SOME OF
THESE PRODUCTS BURKE UP WITH
MALTA SOMETHING THAT OF
INDIVIDUAL FEEDBACK COMICAL
EVERY SINGLE PRODUCT CONTAINS AT
LEAST A DIFFERENT PATH ALL OF
WHICH ARE ASSOCIATED WITH A WIDE
ARRAY OF HEALTH HARMS INCLUDING
CAN'T. PRESS WHAT- AND
DISRUPTION ALL COME UP ALL
CRESSMAN TESTED FROM THE STATES
CONTAIN A PIZZA COMICAL CALLED
FORD HOW ALSO WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
PHASED BY THE FDA TWENTY TWO TO
CONCERN ABOUT PROCESS OF
FEEDBACK COMICAL INTERFOR. THE
PRODUCT ACCEPTED THAT REMOTE
LIKELY TO CONTAIN FOR WHAT
APPROVED BY COLOR BUT- AND FROM
THE- AND THESE ARE ALL THE MOST
LIKELY TO RESULT IN HELP HARM
BECAUSE OF THEIR USAGE. FOR
EXAMPLE MASCARA IS APPLIED TO
THE I AREA WORKING TO THE BODY
FEATURE DOC PEOPLE WHO USE BUT
THANK AN IMPORTANT COMPOUNDS
THAT DOCTOR LIFE AND FOUNDATIONS
APPLIED ACROSS THE ENTIRE FEE.
IS EXTREMELY CONCERNING THE FACT
ARE FOUND IN PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
A HIGH POTENTIAL FOR HUMAN
EXPOSURE ESPECIALLY THE
CONCENTRATION COMMONLY FOUND IN
COSMETICS OFTEN EXCEED SAFE
DRINKING. WATER LEVEL. I THINK
THE INCREDIBLE CARE PRODUCTS NOT
ONLY A- BUT- HARMS PEOPLE OVERLY
. OF THE FACT ARE OPEN FOR IN
OTHER PARTS OF PRODUCTS USED BY
WHO DON'T WEAR MAKE. SUCH AS WHO
ARE MUCH- OUR THIRTY ALL
DISCOVERED THAT MOST OF THE TIME
FIFTY WERE NOT EVEN PRESENT
INGREDIENTS FONG PRODUCT- LABEL
. IN FACT THE ONLY THREE ACROSS
WITHIN FEEDBACK HAD INCLUDED ON
THE INC LIST ONE REASON FOR THIS
BUT IF I SOME PEOPLE ASKING FROM
INADVERTENT. THERE IN YOUR- AND
IT HIM OCCURS BY THE WAY AND
UNNECESSARY USE A FACT BUILT
SUCH AS ONE. WHAT. OTHER KEY
FACTS ARE TO MAKE UP INTENT. BUT
ARE OFTEN LABEL WHICH MEANS THAT
FOLKS CONSUMERS AND OUR COUNTRY
AND INCOME. COULD NOT SHOOT
PROTECT THEM. WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON WHY SUCH. IF NEED. AND
AMONG FOLLOWING OUR RESEARCH
EVEN MAIN MAKE COMPANIES LIKE
KILEY. OR AND VOEPEL I PLEDGE
THEIR NEW EATING WHEN CONTAIN
PEOPLE. AND MIGHT. WORKING WITH
COSMETICS. HELP THEM REMOVE
ATHENEX BIKING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND OUR WEBSITE PEOPLE
THE PRICE HOW THOUSANDS OF
AGREEMENT. THE BOSTON BUT WHAT
THE PEOPLE WANT IT CLEAR TO GO
UP THEIR LIVES HAVING WORRY
ABOUT THE PRODUCT USE ARE.
ESPECIALLY THE THAT ARE CONTACT
THEIR SKIN EVERY DAY. THE
FINANCES CLEAR FEEDBACK FOR HER
. AND SHOULD NOT BE AND CARE.
WELL THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT STUFF. AND DIFFERENT
YOU. NO PEOPLE TO GETTING DETAIL
BY FIND HAVE. HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
LOCK. THE CHEMICAL STRUCTURE. OF
STRONG. FLUORINE FONG DETER
FUNCTION. BUT ALSO THE TERM HOW
AND THEN BY. HARM WHICH IS WHY
BANNING MEANS. CLASS OF PEOPLE.
OF NECESSARY. TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. MY THANK HAS
BEEN I SUPPORT. A TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE FOR THE COUNTRY
COULD GREATLY. THE HEALTH OF OUR
CITIZENS AND THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- AT THE TIME ALASKA
THERE'S ANY WAY IN THE HEARING.
IN AB SEVEN SEVENTY ONE. KEN
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO REJOICING SINCE
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR CAMPAIGN
FOR SAFE COSMETICS THANK YOU.
FOR. WHAT WILL IT BE WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
WHO KNEW WHAT ELSE DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM- THE
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL FROM. OKAY
YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BERS MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL-
TODAY I AM JOINED BY DR J.
ANSELL WHO IS A PC PC'S VICE
PRESIDENT OF COSMETIC PROGRAMS
HE IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE- WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY IN AN- OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE
APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE HOWEVER WE
ARE- STILL REMAIN AND- OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE. IN CONCEPT WE
SUPPORT THE PHASE OUT OF FOSSIL
COSMETICS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS. HOWEVER OUR BIGGEST
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS A LACK
OF NEW ONES AROUND WHAT IT IS
EXACTLY THAT WERE BANDING. THIS
BILL AS DRAFTED BANDS ALL P.
FIVE SWITCH AS DEFINED CAPTURES
ANYTHING THAT HAS FULLY
FLUORINATED CARBON ATOMS. THIS
WOULD CAPTURE OTHER FLUORIDES
LIKE TFA WHICH ARE READY PRESENT
IN THE WATER SUPPLY SO. CLAYS
ETCETERA. TO BE CLEAR WE WILL
NOT INTENTIONALLY ADD P. FIVE US
INTO OUR PRODUCTS. HOWEVER IF
COMPANIES ARE USING MINERALS AND
WATER THERE MAY STILL BE
TECHNICALLY UNAVOIDABLE TRACE
LEVELS IN THE WATER AND
THEREFORE GET INTO THE PRODUCT.
THIS DOES TWO THINGS IT MAKES US
LIABLE FOR INGREDIENTS THAT WE
ARE NOT INTENTIONALLY ADDING
INTO OUR PRODUCTS BUT ARE RATHER
UBIQUITOUS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND NUMBER TWO. IT COULD
PROHIBIT MANUFACTURERS FROM
USING WATER OR OTHER NATURAL
MINERALS AS A COSMETIC
INGREDIENT AND JUST OF THE
COMMITTEES A WHERE WATER IS THE
SINGLE MOST USE INGREDIENTS IN
COSMETICS. COSMETICS AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COMPANIES
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ADVANCING
INNOVATIVE PRODUKTIVNOST. AS
ADDRESSED ABOVE. AND JUST AS A
REMINDER IN TWENTY TWENTY PC PC
AND A WIDE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS- JOINTLY SUPPORTED
A PHASE OUT OF CERTAIN P. FOSS
IN AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
WHICH MOVED OUT OF THIS BODY.
THIS LEGISLATION ONLINE
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH THE E. U. M.
ANNEXED TO FOR COSMETICS AND
PROVIDED CONSISTENCY AND A
PREDICTABLE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK. WE ARE ASKING FOR
THIS M. AND THE SPELL. THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. ARE LARGELY CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE NEGOTIATED IN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO. NUMBER ONE IT'S
A IT'S A CONSISTENT DEFINITION
OF INGREDIENT- NUMBER TWO AS
MENTIONED EARLIER INTENTIONALLY
ADDED IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
NUMBER THREE LANGUAGE AROUND-
TECHNICALLY UNAVOIDABLE TRACE
CONTAMINANTS MUST BE INCLUDED AS
GUARDRAILS IN THE BILL. NUMBER
FOUR WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE AN
INTERNATIONAL DEFINITION OF P.
FIVE US BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS
OPERATE GLOBALLY ANDNO THOSE
INTERNATIONAL DEFINITIONS AND
RECOGNIZE THEM AND KNOW HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THEM. NUMBER FOUR IS
A SOUTH OF PERIOD SO THAT
RETAILERS AREN'T BURDENED WITH
HAVING TO DISPOSE OF THESE
MATERIALS UPON THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THIS BILL WHICH COULD.
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENTAL- BURDEN
BECAUSE THOSE PRODUCTS HAVE TO
BE DISPOSED OF AS HAZARDOUS
WASTE. AND THEN FINALLY A
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATE THAT
ALIGNS WITH AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO ONCE AGAIN PASSED BY
THIS BODY WHICH IS JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
AND THANKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU AND I
WILL CALL ON DR J. ANSELL AFTER
WE GET THROUGH WITH A WITNESSES
AT A RENDERING SO WHO HAD COME
FORWARD AND- HELLO. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON OF COOKING UNITS
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION.
WHOSE MEMBERS INCLUDE BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE AEROSOL INDUSTRY
SUPPLY CHAIN. AS WELL AS THE
FRAGRANCE CREATORS ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS THE LEAD FRAGRANT IT
ASSOCIATION WITH MEMBERSHIP.
COMPRISING OF BUSINESSES ACROSS
THE FRAGRANCE OF POT CHAIN- IN
ADDITION TO THE CONCERNS AND
AMENDMENTS LAID OUT BY ME DEEPLY
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT
THE BROAD DEFINITION. OF P. FAST
IN THIS BILL WOULD REMOVE HF
FOES WHICH ARE USED AS AEROSOL
PROPELLANTS FROM THE COSMETIC
MARKET. AGE OF THOSE OF EMERGED
AS IT. AN AEROSOL AT THAT THE U.
S. EPA HAS DEEMED ACCEPTABLE AS
IT RELATES TO HUMAN HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. HFO IS A VERY
LOW GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL AND
REDUCE GROUND LEVEL OZONE
FORMATION GIVING THEM AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN REACHING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. FOR EXAMPLE
THE HFO ONE TWO THREE FOUR Z. E.
AEROSOL PROPELLANT IS VITAL FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO HAVE AVAILABLE
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH UPCOMING
LOWER VOC LIMITS ESTABLISHED BY
CAR. IN CONTRAST TO BE FAST EACH
OF THOSE ARE NOT PERSISTENT OR
BIO ACCUMULATIVE FURTHER THE U.
S. EPA'S WORKING DEFINITION FOR
THEIR P. FOSS REPORTING ROLE.
ESTABLISHED UNDER THE BY AN
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT INCLUDE
HFO IS AN TO THE EPA'S MASTER
LIST OF NINE THOUSAND P. FAST
SUBSTANCES THAT WAS REFERENCED
IN THE ANALYSIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE HFO ONE TWO THREE FOUR Z. E.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AMENDMENT TO ALLOW THE USE OF
EACH OPPOSE GIVEN THEIR ROLE IN
ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
CLIMATE AMBITIONS. AND PROVIDING
SAFE PRODUCTS TO CONSUMERS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS IN HOPES OF ADDRESSING
THESE CONCERNS BUT TODAY WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF FOR
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE DR J.
ANSELL. WITH THE PC PC. ON THE
PHONE LINE. YEAH YEAH AND THE
LINE IS OPEN WITHIN SPECIFIC
GIVING OPPOSITION. WHAT'S THE TO
SEPARATE QUESTIONS CAN HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS OKAY OKAY OKAY
YOU HAVE ANY OF ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IN A ROW. K.
WILL OPEN IT UP TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
OPERATOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN THERE. NINE
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR BY KAREN MEMBERS JESSICA
GEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES REPRESENTING AROUND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PUBLIC
WASTEWATER TREATMENT AGENCIES IN
OCTOBER OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON THIS IS
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS SANTIAGO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ONE ONE
HAND YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JIM WOOD
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE AND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS EMILY ROGERS ZERO
TOXICS ADVOCATE WITH YOU ASK HER
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND FAMILY WITH HELP
FIRST AND THANK THE PORT ALSO
ACTIVELY SUPPORT FOR THE ENERGY
BEING NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL THANK. NINE ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JORDAN
WELCOME BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. NINE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE FOURTEENTH OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER MEMBERS ADAMANTLY
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
TWENTY ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ANDREA EVAN
TURNER WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POLITICAL PARTY KERN DIRECTOR F
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS BUT
AMERICAN BIRD CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SYMPATHETIC WITH AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. NINE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
ONE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE FOR AB
SEPT TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE AUTHOR
. SEEING NONE I DO HAVE A MOTION
AND- OKAY SERVICE. M. AT LEAST
REMEMBER SERVICE THING THANKS
FOR IN THE BILL I THINK I AM YOU
KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE EVERYBODY
INCLUDING OPPOSITION FOR THOSE
THAT WE HEARD FROM TODAY AGREE
THAT- MORE P. FAST COULD BE
REMOVED FROM THE LIST THAT WE
PASSED UNDER MEROM STRATEGY
FELL. IN A RIVER HAVE YEARS AGO
I WAS- BUT I GUESS I'M A LITTLE
BIT. I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY THIS
BILL ISN'T SORT OF USING THE
SAME FRAMEWORK AND JUST ADDING
THOSE P. FAST TO MR MERCER TWO
THREE MARKETING WORK FOR TWO
YEARS ON I THINK. WE GOT TO A
REALLY GOOD PLACE. WELL BECAUSE-
THERE'S A WHOLE RANGE OF THESE
PRODUCTS AND WHAT SOMETIMES
HAPPENS IS THAT THE FORMULA A-
BILL CHANGE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
FORMULATION BUT ESSENTIALLY
YOU'RE STILL DOING. THE FAUCET.
SO IT'S BETTER TO WHAT IT COMES
TO LARGE CLASSES OF CHEMICALS
LIKE THIS TO ADDRESS THEM AS A
CLASS. BECAUSE IT DOESN'T TAKE
MUCH FOR THEM TO TWEAK IT AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S ON THE LIST
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS WHOLE
LONG PROCESS AGAIN. OKAY THAT'S
THAT'S WHY IT HASN'T WORKED TO
DO IT SORT OF ONE BY ONE. SO
COULD WE HAVE THE WHOLE CLASS OF
P. FIVE TO THE FRAMEWORK CREATED
BY THE- I. WHATEVER THE NUMBER
WITH A CUSTOMER SEARCHES FELL
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SIX YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT
THAT BILL TO KNOW HOW MUCH OF IT
IS A LINE- BUT THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE TRYING TO ADD TO. THE
CLASS OF CHEMICALS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW EVEN AFTER THAT THE OLDER
STILL. RIGHT WAY TOO MUCH OF
THIS IN THE PRODUCTS AND IT'S
STILL GETTING INTO THE WATER. SO
WE FEEL THAT WE NEED TO HAVE AN
YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
TO REALLY FROM ALL THAT OUT. AND
I AND I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND AND-
AS I SAID. WHEN I BEGAN I HAVE.
A SUPPORT I GUESS. YOU KNOW PART
OF WHAT I THINK WORK THIS
COMMITTEE WORKED. HARD ON IN
THAT PROCESS AND IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO THIS. WAS THIS PIECE
ABOUT. YOU KNOW THAT AT. WITH WE
COMMENTED ON ABOUT. THE YOU KNOW
THE UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED THAT
YOU KNOW THE PARTS THAT ARE
COMING FROM SAY WATER OTHER
INGREDIENTS AND I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE- YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE- DOING THAT
WHICH I THINK. MR RESEARCH YOU
DID A GOOD JOB OF MAKING SURE
WAS DONE IN THE END OF HIS BILL
BUT IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE NOW BACK
TO SQUARE ONE AND I'M JUST
FEELING LIKE. WHY RE WE
RENEGOTIATING. VINEGARS YEAH.
BACK TO SQUARE ONE I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE BUILDING ON THE- EXCELLENT
WORK THAT HE DID. IS REALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING. FORGET AT OKAY
DO IT SO I GUESS I'D WANT TO
HEAR FROM OF YOU I ARE YOU
COMMITTEE TO GETTING TO
BASICALLY WHERE WE GOT TO IN
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH
WAS INSURING THAT THOSE FILES
THAT ARE NOT INTENSELY ADDED
THAT ARE JUST IN THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT END UP IN THESE PRODUCTS
ARE NOT PART OF WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON. DIFFERENT TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE COSMETIC INDUSTRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
INTENTIONALLY ADDED ACCOUNT WE
DON'T WANNA YOU KNOW WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT
SORT OF THIS LOOPHOLE AND HE
COULDN'T THEY THEY CAN JUST SAY
HEY WE DON'T MEAN TO SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LETTER OF
SUPPORT THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT
OF COSMETIC COMPANIES HAVE
SIGNED ON IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- AND- AS YOU HEARD EVEN THE
OPPOSITION. I KNOW WE HAVE TO DO
THIS THEY KNOW THERE'S STILL A
PROBLEM SO WE'RE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH THEM AND THE FACT THAT I
DID REACH OUT TO THEM BEFORE WE
EVEN STEP TO SAY WE'RE THINKING
OF DOING THIS WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND- WE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM
AND I THINK I'M BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN REALLY GOOD PARTNERS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
DOABLE FOR THAT WE'RE NOT HOW TO
DO A GUY. WE WANT TO PUSH THEM.
ALL THE MANUFACTURER. WE CLING.
THEIR ACT. BECAUSE NONE OF US.
WE ALL WANT TO. HELLO THOUGH HE
BUYS A- ON THE SHOW. HERE THAT
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT HURTING
OURSELVES. ARE HEARD AND WATER
SUPPLIES WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM. SEVEN CAN YOU ADDRESS
THE- M. TICKET. THE ANALYSIS
ACTUALLY TALKED. CHAU WHICH I'D
NEVER. BEFORE READING THE
ANALYSIS OF THE HONEST- BUT- ARE
WE ADDRESSING THAT CONCERN.
ANALYSIS IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THERE'S ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THAT'S- POSING THE SAME CONCERN
THE P. FIVE SAYS. SO WE FEEL
THAT THE EVEN THOUGH INNER
DIDN'T REFRIGERATE AND
REFRIGERATE INDUSTRY THESE ARE
SAFE PRODUCTS BUT THERE'S ALSO
EVIDENCE THAT WHETHER YOU SOME
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT COME
IN CONTACT WITH WATER THEY TURN
INTO ANOTHER MATERIAL. WHICH IS
CALLED TFA WHICH DOES HAVE
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS SO WE'RE
SAYING FINE USE THAT IN YOUR
REFRIGERATION PRODUCTS BUT LET'S
NOT PUT INTO PRODUCTS THAT WERE
SPRING ON OUR BODIES THAT END UP
NEXT IN WATER. BECAUSE THOSE
HEALTH IMPACTS IT'S NOT SO CLEAR
ABOUT THAT SO BENIGN. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE
BECAUSE THERE ARE KNOWN
ALTERNATIVES RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
USED. AT OUR STATE WHICH IS
COMPRESSED AIR OR NITROGEN. AND
ALSO THE OF THE H. OPPOSE ARE
NOT. MEDICS AT THIS POINT SO YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO DISRUPT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN COSMETICS WE JUST
DON'T WANT THEM TO BE USED UNTIL
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE REALLY SAFE
YOU KNOW IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS. VERITY AND VERITY
BEING I DON'T KNOW AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE THEY'RE BEING USED IN
AEROSOLS RIGHT WHICH ARE YOU.
KNOW THEY'RE NOT. OKAY SURE.
SURE IF I COULD- EACH OF THOSE
ARE JUST NOW BEING- THE PLAN IS
TO INTRODUCE THEM AS AN AEROSOL.
AND ACCORDING TO EWG HAS ITS
LARGE SKIN DEEP DATABASE AND WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND.
PRODUCTS THAT WE HAVE-
INGREDIENTS FOR AND WE DID A
POLL OF THAT. AND FOUND THAT
ONLY TWO OF THOSE PRODUCTS
CONTAINED IT H. F. O.'S OKAY.
AND SO IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING-
FROM. TALKING WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS THAT. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE POISED
TO BRING INTO THE MARKET AND SO
WE WOULD JUST HOPE THAT THEY
WOULD. MAYBE TRY TO PIT YOU KNOW
AWAY BECAUSE IT IT DOES ACTUALLY
BREAK DOWN INTO ANOTHER TYPE OF
P. FAST WHICH IS THE TFA THAT IS
A PERSISTENT CHEMICAL. IN THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
WILL CONTINUE TO ACCELERATE
CONTACT M. AS A CHILD OF THE
EIGHTIES WHO LEFT MY HAIR SPRAY.
AND REMEMBERS WHEN WE ALL HAD TO
GET RID OF OUR AEROSOL HAIRSPRAY
IS BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT ON. THE
VARMINTS- AND I KNOW THAT SOME
OF OUR FRIEDMAN IS ALWAYS
LOOKING OUT FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ENVIRONMENT JUST MAKING SURE
THAT IT ISN'T SORT OF A MORE
BENEFICIAL. USE THE WORD
WEIGHING ALL OF THE- THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING HERE YET- THE TFA
IS VERSUS THE IMPACT THAT THESE
PRODUCTS HAVE A MUCH. LARGER
GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT. AND THEN MY
LAST QUESTION WAS THE AND THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE SELL THROUGH
DATE AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE. HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT
AND WHETHER OR NOT THERE WILL BE
TIME FOR THESE INDUSTRIES TO.
GET RID OF WHAT'S ALREADY ON THE
SHELVES ARE IN THE MARKET WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THEM. YEAH.
WITH A HUGE HAZARDOUS WASTE
PROBLEM. OUT LAUGHING. THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
SIMILAR POWER QUE HAN I DID SEE
THE OPPOSITION FLINCH OUT THERE
BUT I'M GONNA GO TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYOR SEARCHING FOR
RESPONSIBLE. THANK YOU I JUST
WANTED TO THANK A- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR. TRYING TO
FINISH TO WHAT I CONSIDER
UNFINISHED BUSINESS OF EFFORT
FROM MY BILL FROM TWENTY TWENTY-
YOU KNOW THE SAME. SCIENCE
APPLIES TO- B. A CLASS OF P.
FOSS THAT THAT YOUR- SEEKING TO
BAN- AS AS THE CHEMICALS FOR MY
TWENTY TWENTY BILL ON THAT THE
SAME. CANCER CAUSING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HARMING.
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITY CAUSING-
PROPENSITIES OF THESE CHEMICALS-
HEY I JUST WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
FOR THE- FOR THIS COMMITTEE
THAT- THAT- YOU KNOW THE ONLY
REASON WHY WE DIDN'T INCLUDE
THESE AND OUR EARLIER BILL WAS
BECAUSE- OUR EARLIER OUR
REGIONAL VERSION OF OUR BILL.
DIED IN THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND SO WAS IT WAS A
MORE OUT OF TOWN BECAUSE OF THE
POLITICS RATHER THAN THE POLICY-
BUT I AM FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. YOU'RE TRYING TO
REPAIR IT THANK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE OPPOSITION
WANT TO SAY I'VE SEEN SOME
MOVEMENT BACK THERE. WE CALLING
WITNESSES BACK UP YES SHE PICKED
SHE HAS TO BE CALLED BACK UP SO
YES. GO AHEAD. I JUST M. IT
REALLY ANSWERED IT BUT YES WE
ARE MOVING INTO HFO IS FOR
MANUFACTURING OF SOME AEROSOL
PRODUCTS AND AS A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN DID MENTION COMPRESSED
GAS IS AN OPTION IN SOME PRODUCT
THAT'S NOT ALL- I WILL NOTE THAT
WITHOUT- THIS HFO WHICH IS
REPLACING THE HSCS DUE TO A TWO
YEAR. MAYBE THREE YEAR-
REGULATORY PROCESS WE CONDUCTED
A CARB OUT WITHOUT IT-
MANUFACTURES MAY HAVE TO MOVE TO
BUTANE- WHICH IS FLAMMABLE BUT
WOULD NOT BE CAUGHT UP BY THIS
BILL SO- AGAIN JUSTIN WEIGHING
THOSE ALTERNATIVES- AT THE
POSSIBILITY. THANK YOU FOR. I DO
HAVE A LOOK I DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. AND THEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. IN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY- I'M SO SORRY BUT
THAT'S OKAY OFFER TO CLOSE JUST
THAT WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
TALK TO INDUSTRY AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS WORKABLE FOR EVERYBODY. AND I
APPRECIATE THEIR COUNCIL AND
THEIR PARTNERSHIP SO FAR ON THE
BILL. AND I WOULD REDUCE ASPIRIN
AYE VOTES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION THANK YOU. I
DON'T GET THIS POSITION TOO
OFTEN SO EXCUSE ME. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COMPLEX I WERE TO GET
TO CLOSE AS WELL. IN THE SAME
BOAT. SURE AND AT YOUR- HELLO AS
YOU IN ASPECTS. HAS TO MENTION
THAT IS OUR IN A AYE VOTE. I
DON'T FOUR BEACH SEVEN SEVENTY.
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH CORK. HI SMITH. NO WITH
THIS TIME BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION SMITH NO
ARAMBULA. REGULAR I'D STARKEY
HAD. OKAY HAND I CRISTINA GARCIA
. CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN.
MATHIS MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
WALDRON. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. BUT SO FAR. LAST FILM OF
THE DAY I THOUGHT IT WAS NEXT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THE FORWARD YEAH. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER
K. HAND NEONICOTINOID PESTICIDES
PROHIBITED NON AGRICULTURAL USE
. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT VERY STRONG
CLARIFICATION THERE AND I WANT
TO THINK THAT CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS BILL
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND
WE'VE REALLY BEEN A PARTNERSHIP
FOR COULD THINK GIVEN MAYBE A
YEAR- TO TRY TO GET TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY AND I THINK IT'S IN A
REALLY GOOD PLACE AND THAT'S IN
LARGE PART DUE TO YOUR EFFORTS
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL. AT
SO BECAUSE OF THE COMMITTEES
THAT REQUEST I WANT TO BE CLEAR
I'M ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS TO
BETTER REFLECT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS MOVING TO
RESTRICT. AN ASSOCIATION CLARIFY
. THAT IT'S FOR AGRICULTURAL
USES ONLY. AND SHORING UP THE
EMERGENCY YOU MEAN NON
AGRICULTURAL NOT A GREAT THANK
YOU. BAKER CULTURALLY THAT. M.
SO WE'RE HERE TODAY REALLY TO
FOCUS ON WHAT IS A PROBLEM
PLAGUING CALIFORNIA AND TO BE
FRANK THE ENTIRE WORLD WHICH IS
AB THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE KILLING
OUR BEE POPULATION WHICH ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
BIODIVERSITY BUT ALSO TO OUR
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY-
CALIFORNIA BEEKEEPERS LOST OVER
41% OF THEIR EARNINGS LAST YEAR
ONE OF THE WORST YEARS ON
RECORD. EVIDENCE IS MOUNTING
THAT THIS PRIMARILY CAUSED BY
PESTICIDES AND SPECIFICALLY THE
CLASS OF PESTICIDES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY
NEONICOTINOIDS LHASA POLLINATORS
ENDANGERS UPWARDS OF ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
STATE AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION
AND IS ALREADY LIMITING DEALS
AND DRIVING UP FOOD PRICES THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BEES TO
POLLINATE OUR PLANTS FOOD IS
HARDER TO GROW AND PRICES RISE
AND RIGHT NOW WITH PRICES RISING
ALREADY IN FOOD AND OTHER
NECESSITIES IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
WE DO WHAT WE CAN. TO PROTECT
OUR FOOD CROPS CALIFORNIA HAS A
ROBOT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
REGULATING PESTICIDES AND A
PERMANENT SIDE REGULATIONS HAS
ALREADY INCREASED RESTRICTIONS
OF NEONICOTINOIDS IN THE
AGRICULTURAL SETTING. THAT'S WHY
WE'RE FOCUSED ON NOT
AGRICULTURAL HERE TODAY- AND
THOSE ARE THE GAPS THAT WE SEE
FOR THE USE OF THESE CHEMICALS
NEONICOTINOID USE ON LAWNS
GARDENS AND GOLF COURSES IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY UNNECESSARY
USERS COVER THEIR PROPERTY WITH
GRANULES AND WATER THEM INTO THE
SOIL MANY LONDONERS DON'T EVEN
KNOW THIS IS HAPPENING THE
CHEMICALS PROCEED TO SEEP INTO
THE WATER SUPPLY TRAVEL TRIP TO
SPENDING IT'S AN ABSORBENT PLAN
THAT. NADER'S CONSUME. COMMENTS
ARE LEARN AS A I NEED AND ARE A-
BUT ALTERNATIVES LIKE DYNAMITE
THAT CAN REPLACE NEAR NEXT WHEN
NECESSARY. THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUED THAT THE BILL LIMITS
NECESSARY USE OF NEONICS IN
ADDITION TO THESE NON
ALTERNATIVES I WANNA BE CLEAR
ABOUT THE WHAT THE BILL EXEMPTS
THE BILL INCLUDES EXEMPTIONS TO
ALLOW FOR EXTERMINATION USE USE
FOR INVASIVE SPECIES AND OTHER
NECESSARY USES THE POSE LIMITED
RISK TO POLLINATORS. OTHER
COUNTRIES AND STATES WE WON'T BE
THE FIRST DAY AND THEN YOU NEED
TO DO THIS HAVE ALREADY
RECOGNIZE THE HARMS OF NEONICS.
THEY ALREADY ARE BANNED IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION FOR NEARLY ALL
USES THE NEW JERSEY HAS BANDS
THEIR NON AGRICULTURAL USE IN
EXACTLY THE WAY WERE
CONTEMPLATING TODAY. IT'S TIME
THE CALIFORNIA CATCHES UP WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD TO ADDRESS
THE LOSS OF OUR POLLINATORS AND
THE HEALTH OF OUR ENVIRONMENT
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT ARE
ANDREA WILLIAMS DIRECTOR BIO
DIVERSITY INITIATIVES. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND LUCAS ROADS AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE NRDC POLLINATOR PROGRAM WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. ARE
VERY GOOD AND THEY'RE ON THE
PHONE LINE. YES ALL RIGHT- WHO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK FIRST.
AT ANDREA ANDREA UP YOU SHOULD
HAVE A LIFELINE. AND IF YOU WELL
LET'S START TAKE YOURSELF OFF
MUTE AND START SPEAKING WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON TWENTY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ANDREA WILLIAMS I'M THE
DIRECTOR BY THE NATION'S FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY.
ARE JOINING THEIR STUFF I HAD
OVER TWENTY YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
PUBLIC PUBLIC LANDS MANAGEMENT
OF THE VEGETATION ECOLOGIST AND
ALSO AN INVENTORY AND MONITORING
BIOLOGISTS AND ASSISTED IN
SEVERAL BE BUTTERFLY AND
POLLINATOR. CALIFORNIA IS A BAD
HOT. REPORTER TO HAVE MORE TYPES
OF PLANT AND ANIMAL THE NEW THE
STATE. THAT INCLUDES OUR BE SOME
WHICH ARE NOWHERE ELSE ON OUR-
WHEN YOU'RE REALLY ADVANCEMENT
THAT DIVERSITY IS THREATEN BY
NEARLY MOVES SOMETIMES YEARS. UP
SCIENTISTS HAVE FOUND THE ANNEX
AND WE PLAN TO MANY SIX YEAR
COAST. ON IF ARE BEES CONNECTION
. YOU'RE NOT GOING AND SO L. A.
HE TAKES UP ON YOUR PLANTS WITH
ARE PRESENT IN EVERY PART
INCLUDE NEEDS IN AND TEACH. YOUR
NEXT CAN KILL THESE EXTRA LOW.
PHOTOGRAPH TREATED WITH ANY ON.
GROUP LEVELS. CONTAINER OF JUST
EXPOSURE TO ON THE KNOWLEDGE OF
REDUCED. A BILL. PARTICULARLY IN
THE- OUTPUT. AND INCREASE THE
BILL TO PARASITES. THANK SISTER
GENERATION. I AM ON THE PHONE OF
THE FOOD WEB THE AND THE EFFECTS
ARE SEEN IN FISH REPTILES CROSS
ENAMEL INCLUDE WAKE TIRE
MORTALITY RATES PARTICULAR FOR
YOUNG ANIMALS- WERE WITH
COMMUNITIES WITH LEARNED THAT
THE MAIN REASON MANY PEOPLE
GARDEN WITH PLANTS WHICH TO
CREATE HAVOC. FOR BIRDS ABOUT A
ANOTHER WOULD BE. THAT'S WHY
MANY OF THE NATIVE PLANTS IS A
LOT ABOUT THE NUMBERS OF
ALLOCATED AGAINST UNIX WHICH THE
YEAR. YES SUPPORTERS BILL WHICH
MAKES IT EASY FOR PEOPLE ON AND
HARM AND- I THINK THE CAN FOR
THEIR ATTENTION AND I BELIEVE
WITH THIS ON THE LINE TO OTHER
CONTENT- HELP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANDREA OUR NEXT FOR LOW.
ROWE AND ARE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
MISTER KIRK YOU HEAR ME ARE YEAH
YEAH. THE FACT THAT I GET UP TO
MEMBERS OF THE AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING UP THIS CRITICAL BILL HI
MY NAME IS LUCAS ROAD CONTEST ON
BEHALF OF AN RDC AND ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA- URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO ADVANCE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SIX. FOLLOW PETE MADE OF THE
EUROPEAN UNION NEW JERSEY AND
MAINE THE BAN ON HARMFUL AND
UNNECESSARY USES OF NEONICS HAVE
BEEN GREAT I'VE EXPLAINED
MUNICH'S HAVE WIDESPREAD
ECOLOGICAL EFFECTS THEY'VE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS THE LEADING CAUSE
OF BEE DECLINES FRIGHTENING
POLLINATOR SERVICES THAT SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY. ALSO WHEN COULD NOT
THE- CLUB AQUATIC KEEP. AND EVEN
BIRTH DFECTS IN WHITE TAILED
DEER. OUTDOOR NON AGRICULTURAL
USES TARGETED BY THIS BILL ARE
CONTRIBUTING SIGNIFICANTLY TO
THIS CRISIS. WHAT ARE CUTTING
BACK CALIFORNIA DPR HAS FOUND AT
LEAST ONE UNIT IN 92% OF SURFACE
WATER SAMPLES IN URBAN AREAS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUGGESTING THAT NON AGRICULTURAL
USES OF NEONICS ARE A MAJOR
SOURCE OF POLLUTION. IT ALSO
PROVIDES EVIDENCE OF UBIQUITOUS
CONTAMINATION OF NOT JUST
CALIFORNIA'S BORDER BUT ALSO
IT'S SO IT'LL AND PLANT LIFE.
INSEMINATION EVEN EXTENDS TO OUR
BODIES CDC MONITORING SHOWS THAT
HALF OF AMERICANS ARE EXPOSED TO
NEONICS ON ANY GIVEN DAY BUT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS FOUND IN
CHILDREN. RESEARCH INDICATES
INCREASINGLY INDICATE CAUSE FOR
CONCERN ABOUT EXPOSURE TO THESE
NEUROTOXIC CHEMICALS. MEDINA
LOGICAL STUDIES LINKING UNIX
WITH INCREASED RISK OF
MALFORMATIONS OF THE DEVELOPING
HEART AND BRAIN AND RODENT
STUDIES LINKING THE ANNEX WITHIN
OUR LOGICAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
HARMS. WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO
ALLOW NEEDLESS EXPOSURE TO THESE
CHEMICALS. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
NON AGRICULTURAL USES ARE
UNNECESSARY FOR REPLACEABLE.
BECAUSE NEONICS ARE SYSTEMIC
THEY'RE ALMOST ALWAYS APPLIED
PREVENTIVELY BEFORE THERE IS ANY
EVIDENCE OF A PATH PROBLEM SO IN
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES THE BEST
ALTERNATIVE TO USING NEONICS IS
NOTHING. BUT EVEN WHERE THERE
THE PAST PROBLEM THERE ARE OTHER
EFFECTIVE AND LESS HARMFUL
OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR ALL THESE
REASONS NRDC STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND REQUEST HER AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- NEXT
I'D LIKE TO HEAR THE PRIMARY-
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. AND.
LET'S SEE I HAVE PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YEAH YEAH I JUST THAT
HAVE A SEAT WE LIKE TO SEE YOU.
YOU'RE ONE OF OUR FRIENDS. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CHAIR MEMBERS KNOW
COOKING UNITS AGAIN HERE AGAIN
ON THAT- BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD
AND COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION WHOSE MEMBER
COMPANIES MANUFACTURE NON
AGRICULTURAL USE NEONICOTINOID
BASED PRODUCTS OTHER USED TO
CONTROL PESTS SUCH AS BED BUGS
FLIES- STINK BUGS COCKROACHES-
CERTAIN INVASIVE SPECIES AND-
CONTROLLING PAT PASSED- INSECTS
SUCH AS FLEAS AND TICKS-
CONSUMER PASS PRODUCTS ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS THE ABILITY TO
CLEAN AND PROTECT THEIR HOMES
AGAINST A VARIETY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PASS WITH SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE PRODUCTS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO SUCH PRODUCTS.
CONSUMERS MUST CHOOSE BETWEEN
TAKING NO ACTION AGAINST THESE
PASS OR PAYING SOMEONE TO
PERFORM THOSE SERVICES AS THE
ANALYSIS EXPLAINS AN APPLICATION
OF NEARLY SIX- HAVE BEEN
EVALUATED BY THE U. S. EPA ANTI
PR FOR BOTH ECOLOGICAL AND HUMAN
HEALTH EFFECTS AND THE EPA IS
CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING
REGISTRATION REVIEW OF THE CLASS
OF NEW ANNEX AND EXPECTED TO
FINALISE EVALUATIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO. WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR. AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX ADDRESS THE
USES OF MUNICH PRODUCTS THAT
WERE NOT A PART OF DPR IS A
VALUATION. AT WHICH LOOKS AT OUR
CULTURAL USES IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT DPR CHOSE NOT TO
EVALUATE- RISK IS TO INDOOR USES
STRUCTURAL USES AND NON
AGRICULTURAL OUTDOOR USES SUCH
AS LAWNS GARDENS AND GOLF
COURSES. DUE TO LACK OF
POLLINATOR EXPOSURE- I. E. NOT
ATTRACTIVE TO BEES NO FOOD
SOURCES FOR BEES TO FEED ON AND
LOWER USE RATES OR LACK OF
WIDESPREAD USE ABOUT A QUOTE
FROM A DOCUMENT THAT THEY PUT
OUT. THAT WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
EXEMPTIONS IN THE BILL HOWEVER
WOULD NOTE THAT WHILE THE BILL
EXEMPTS PRODUCTS USED ON. PETS
TO TREAT FLEAS AND TICKS
PRODUCTS WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
BE USED ON PLANTS WHERE THOSE
FLEAS AND TICKS LIVE AND ARE
PICKED UP BY PETS AND BROUGHT
INTO THE HOME. THEREFORE LEAVING
CONSUMERS WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
PREVENT FLEA AND TICK
INFESTATIONS. WE SUPPORT
INITIATIVES TO PROMOTE POLITY-
HEALTH AND BELIEVE IT ITS COMPS
GROWTH COMPLEXITY CALLS FOR
THOUGHTFUL STAKEHOLDER ENGAGE
SOLUTIONS WE ALSO SUPPORT
CONTINUED RESEARCH ON THE REST
TO BE HEALTH AND READILY
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF POLLINATORS TO OUR
ECOSYSTEM AND ECONOMY. HOWEVER
IN RECOGNITION OF THE WORK BY
THE USEPA AND THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE SCIENCE TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX THANK.
VERY GOOD. GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRIDGE THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL- AND
A NUMBER OF OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ORGANIZATIONS WESTERN PLANT
HEALTH ASSOCIATION AND OTHERS.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AND
WANT TO FIRST EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR- AND-
CLEARLY THE INTENT THAT SHE'S
MADE TO- NOT TO BRING
AGRICULTURAL USES INTO THE BILL.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS HELP MOVE IT IN THAT
DIRECTIONS BY TAKING OUT THE
LANGUAGE DEALING WITH
RESTRICTED. USE PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL IS THE
WAY IT'S- SET UP. PRIMARY
CONCERN AT THIS POINT IS THE-
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL DEALING
WITH THE EMERGENCY-
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENT
EMERGENCY. HOW IT OULD PUT TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION. IN THE
LEAD OF ACTUALL DETERMINE WHEN
THERE IS A PASSED EMERGENCY. HI
DPR THEY'RE GREAT WHAT THEY DO
BUT THEY'RE TOXICOLOGIST THEY'RE
NOT ENTOMOLOGISTS. AND SO IT'S
CDFA- THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THE
DETERMINES INVASIVE PESTS LOOKS
AT INVASIVE PRESS PROGRAMS.
ESTABLISHES QUARANTINES
ESTABLISH MEDICATION MEASURES-
THAT DEALS WITH THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES AND SO. I THINK THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE A REALLY RE THOUGHT
ABOUT- IF WE'RE MOVING DOWN THAT
PATHWAY. THEN WE HAVE THE
EXAMPLE OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
CITRUS INDUSTRY- THAT- REALLY
HAS THIS INTERFACE WITH URBAN
USE OF PRODUCTS. HOW WE'VE BEEN
FIGHTING THE ASIAN CITRUS
PSYLLID WHICH TRANSMITS ONE LONG
BANG FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
THERE ARE MORE BACKYARD CITRUS
TREES IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEN THERE ARE CITRUS TREES IN
PRODUCTION. AND IT'S THOSE
BACKYARD CITRUS TREES WERE WE
FOUND THAT THEY HARBOR AND THEY
SPREAD THE ASIAN CITRU PSYLLID.
AND SO WE IN THE CITRUS INDUSTRY
HAVE INVESTED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OVER THE LAST DECADE. ON
A PROGRAM THAT DOES EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH TO THOSE CONSUMERS
TO BETTER PROTECT THEIR TREES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S PRODUCTS AVAILABLE FOR
THAT. NOT ONLY SO CONSUMERS CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE BACK ARE COME
CHRIS AT. CITRUS TREES. BUT THAT
THEY DON'T CREATE THAT
ADDITIONAL HARM. AND EXPOSURE-
TO THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR
COMMERCIAL CITRUS INDUSTRY. AND
OUR FINAL POINT WOULD BE MORE ON
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF PRINCIPLE
WE DO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION IT IS WORLD
RENOWNED. FOR ITS TOXICOLOGIST
AND THE MITIGATION MEASURES IN
THE SCIENCE THAT ARE PUT INTO
THE REGISTRATION OF PRODUCTS
AFTER A PRODUCT IS REGISTERED AT
USEPA IT TAKES ANOTHER THREE TO
FIVE YEARS. ANOTHER TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO REGISTER
THAT PRODUCT FOR THE USE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF WE THINK
THAT THEY'RE RE. MISSED THE
MARK- AS IT RELATES TO THESE
PRODUCTS THEN LET'S ASK THEM TO
DO IT AGAIN THEY CHOSE NOT TO
USE TO LOOK AT THE NON
AGRICULTURAL USES BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THE RISK WAS LOW. IF YOU
THE LEGISLATURE DISAGREED WITH
THAT RATHER THAN TAKING THE
CHEMISTRY AND TAKEN THE SCIENCE
INTO YOUR HANDS LET'S DIRECT
THEM TO GO BACK AND DO WHAT
THEY'RE PAID TO DO REEVALUATE
THAT SCIENCE AND COME BACK TO
ADDITIONAL LIMITATIONS. USE
RESTRICTIONS EXCEPT FOR IF THAT
THE SCIENCE LEAD TO MINUTE
DIRECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL. CAN FOR MY
OKAY SORRY FOR ALL OPEN THE ROOM
TO TESTIMONY FIRST THAT'S IN
FAVOR AND THEN IMPOSED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELISSA LEVY WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL BE- IN
STRONG SUPPORT I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE ON THEIR
BEHALF THANK YOU. VERY GOOD AT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS RIORDAN PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA NUMBER
ONE I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR SPENDING SOME TIME WAS A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO I THINK WE HAD
A VERY CANDID DISCUSSION. ABOUT
SORT OF OUR CONCERNS AND I KNOW
YOU JUST AMENDED A BILL AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH- THAT
VERY MUCH BUT WE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS BASED ON OUR
DISCUSSIONS OF HOW THE SCIENCE I
DETERMINE THE PARTICULAR
EXEMPTION A ONE IN FOUR FEET.
NUMBER ROSSOW CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ROLE OF DPR WHAT THAT MEANS
IN TERMS OF HAVE HAVEN'T SPENT A
LOT TIME FOR MYSELF IT'S THE
DEFINITIVE PESTICIDE USE
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENT IN THE
COUNTRY SO WE THINK IT'S SUPPORT
WHAT THEY DO AS WELL. I THINK WE
ALSO WANT TO WITH AND WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AS WELL SO- WE WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AS
WE PROCEED FOR THIS BILL AND
HOPE THAT- WE COULD MAY RESOLVE
SOME ISSUES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
AT LENGTH AS WELL SO- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELL I LET YOU GO ON
A LITTLE BIT LONGER BUT IT WAS
GOOD TO HEAR YOU IF YOU- AND WE
DO APPRECIATE IT PA PEOPLE
WORKING TOGETHER ALL RIGHT- AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX IS THE BILL
WE'RE HEARING WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE PHONE LINE SO AGAIN. THIS
IS JUST ON AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SIX AND WE WOULD LIKE IT VERY
MUCH IF YOU JUST GIVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU MADAM PHONE OPERATOR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WELL
FIRST GOTO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JONATHAN EVAN IN
PROBLEM HELP LEGAL DIRECTOR AT
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX THANK
YOU. NEXT IN LINE EIGHTY TWO.
SANTIAGO WITH- SANTIAGO
CALIFORNIA BY REPUBLICANS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS
AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE
SUPPORT FROM THEIR CALL
CALIFORNIA. VERY GOOD EXADATA
LINE NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS MARK FENSTER KNOCKED ON
BEHALF OF- CHAPTERS AS WELL AS
REGISTER IN SUPPORT FOR AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF THE POLLINATOR
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL THANKS TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SIX. EXLINE ONE
SEVENTEEN. MICHAEL CHAIR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SIX. AND WE CAN GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS BEING TALLIED
WITH CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
A POSITION AT THE TIME BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AWFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL OPEN ONE SIXTEEN. HELLO THIS IS ABIGAIL MILE ON
BEHALF OF THE MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND WE GOT A LINE ONE EIGHTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. M.
LINE ONE TWENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DENNIS ALBION WITH
CALIFORNIA- GROWERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WEAKER ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION WE
ARE CLOSED AT THIS TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE THANK YOU. AND NEXT WEEK
AN OPEN LINE ONE OH FIVE. HELLO
THIS IS ANDREA VENTURA WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MEANT TO ONE NINETEEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS YOUR DISSERTATION
RESPECTFULLY OTHERS AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. IN NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT MR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND WEBER LINE NINETY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
OPPOSITION. AND NEXT TO FLYING
EIGHTY. NINE EIGHT ZERO. AND
NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN MOVE TO LINE SEVENTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRENDA BACK BUT
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
CONNECTIONS LINE SEVENTY TWO. RT
TURNED WITH THE AMERICAN BIRD
CONSERVANCY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NEXT STEP LINE SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS OF THE
PARALLEL ON BEHALF OF THE DIXIE
SOCIETY FOR INVERTEBRATE
CONSERVATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX. YOU
CAN LOOK ONLINE EIGHTY EIGHT.
HELLO HM MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK
WITH THE GUN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM AND ACTION
NETWORK AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND LAST WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I KEPT UP WITH CALIFORNIA
GOLF COURSE SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO ALLOW
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE CERTIFIED
APPLICATORS THE PLANTER. AND NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW WILL
GET COMMENTS FROM OUR- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YES MR MURATSUCHI AND
MR ARAMBULA DR ARAMBULA. I THANK
YOU AYE AYE A ON WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL BUT I'M
JUST CURIOUS NOW- WITH THE
OPPOSITION'S TESTIMONY ABOUT TO
FLEAS AND TICKS THEM WONDERING
WHAT ALTERS MY DOG WILL HAVE
YOUR DOG DOESN'T NEED ANY
ALTERNATE IS MISTER MURATSUCHI
BECAUSE AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
BILL- IT EXPLICITLY EXEMPTS ANY
PET CARE OF ORDINARY PERSONAL
CARE INDOOR PEST CONTROL HAS
THAT PRODUCT THANK YOU YOU'LL
BE. I WAS PERPLEXED BY THE- WELL
IT HELPS THE PEOPLE READ THE
BILL. DR RAMBLING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA START- I
WAS QUITE MOVED BY THE COMMENTS
ABOUT NEEDING TO HELP TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF OUR BEE POPULATION
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE APIARY
PROTECTION ACT WE PASSED IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND BEFORE THAT
THE B. WHERE PROGRAM WE WORKED
AT I UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
THOSE POLLINATORS PLAY- I DID
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON WHY WE
WOULD NOT I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL HERE TODAY
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE. WHY
WOULD A NASTY PR TO EVALUATE NON
AG YOU. CONCLUSION I. THINK IT'S
LOGICAL FOR US TO. ASK THE
DEPARTMENT THAT'S MADE AN
ASSESSMENT WHY THEY DIDN'T JUST
IN TRYING TO GET CLARITY ON
THAT- SAUCE EVERYTHING BOTH THE
COMMITTEE AND I HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PAIR
ABOUT THIS BILL AND I. I DON'T
KNOW THAT MY ASSESSMENT MY
CONVERSATIONS ALIGNS WITH THE
OPPOSITION THAT THEY THINK THIS
IS A NECESSARY I'LL SAY THAT-
THEY HAVE DONE INCREDIBLE WORK
IN THE AGRICULTURAL SPACE WHICH
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF SMITH.
THAT'S WHAT I RECALLED HER IN
REALLY DEALING WITH SORT OF TIME
OF YEAR SPRAY RIGHT SO WHEN WE
DON'T EXPECT FLOWERS THEY ALLOW
IT WHEN WE DO HAVE FULL POWERS
THEY DON'T BECAUSE THAT REALLY
ALIGNS WITH. PROJECT MANAGERS
YOU THIS IS BEING USED IN OUR
I'M NOT A- REAL SETTINGS WHICH
IS. LOOSELY PUT ON YOUR GRASS
GLASSFORD LONG. AND THEN.
LAUGHED RATE IS IT JUST DOESN'T
ALIGN WITH THE SAME WAY WE SEE
AGRICULTURE. I'M GOING TO TELL
USERS DOING IT JUST THEY OPERATE
DIFFERENTLY THAN ARE AT HOME SO
IT DIDN'T FIT INTO THE SCHEME
THEY WERE USING AND THEY WERE
GOING DOWN THIS PATH. IT IS NOW
BEEN. OF SINCE THEY STARTED THE
PROCESS FOR OUR CULTURAL USES
AND THEY'RE GETTING THERE
THEY'RE NOT THERE YET BUT
THEY'RE GETTING THERE AND THAT'S
WHY WE ARE TOUCHING IT WE THINK
THEY'RE DOING A FINE JOB- BUT
THEY HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED
DISCUSSING THIS AND I'VE I AM
PERPLEXED AND I DID REACH OUT AS
I THINK THE OPPOSITION INDICATED
I REACHED OUT TO OUR
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO TALK ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT I'M NOT ONLY
ARE WE NOT TARGETING THEM IN
THIS BILL WE BELIEVE THIS IS
BENEFICIAL FOR CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY THEY NEED
THESE BEES AND AS YOU HEARD.
FROM OUR WITNESS WHEN YOU'RE
FINDING NEW UNIX IN 92% OF WATER
SAMPLES COMING OUT OF LOS
ANGELES IT IS PREVALENT AND SO
IT IS GOING TO BE STILL JUST IN
ONE AREA. THE WE BELIEVE BELIEVE
THIS IS BENEFITS. FOR
AGRICULTURE. TO SAY TO BE. DOING
THIS AT HOME. NOT TO DO IT AND
THEN AGAIN TO ALLOW IT UNDER THE
PR SYSTEM FOR THOSE THAT NEED A
NAP CULTURAL SETTING. AND WE DID
AND I WILL SPEAK ALSO TO WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT INVASIVE SPECIES- WHICH
WAS ADDRESSED AN INJURED. YOU'RE
CHOOSING LAW THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
BASIC SPECIES BUT THE- PROBLEM.
HE SAID. WELL AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT AND
WILL BECAUSE WE TRY TO ATTEMPT
THAT WE THOUGHT WE DID A GOOD
JOB BUT YOU DON'T ALWAYS GET IT
RIGHT THE FIRST. SO THIS. ISN'T
WHAT. WE DO. SAID CAL. I LOOK.
AT IT. TO OWN TODAY. BUT HLB.
FOR CITRUS. P. AND AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY HEARING OUR STATE
QUITE A SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT BEING RESOLVED BUT I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BELTWAY
THANK. VERY GOOD DO YOU WANT TO
MAKE THAT A MORE. VERY GOOD.
OTHER COMMENTS. YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THAT ALL RIGHT SO I WOULDN'T SAY
IT'S NOT ONLY POLLINATORS AND
EVEN WELL IN GERMANY THEY KNOW
THAT ABOUT 30% OF THEIR- OF
THEIR INSECTS TOTAL INSECT
POPULATION HAS GONE DOWN. THE
INSECTS ARE AT THE BASE OF THE
FOOD CHAIN. WINDOW IN THE US WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME SORT OF LONG
TERM LOOK AT INSECTS WE NEED ANY
OF THAT. THE BIRD POPULATION
FROM USING THE DOPPLER RADAR IS
DOWN THIRTY PERCENT. GOOD ONE OF
THOSE IS LIKELY TO BE THE FACT
THAT THESE INSECTS THAT. WE
DON'T WANT CERTAIN PLACES REALLY
NEED TO BE IN OTHER PLACES TO
SUPPORT THE BIRD POPULATION AND
OTHER POPULATIONS THIS IS A BASE
OF THE FOOD CHAIN. IT IS VERY
CLEAR TO ME THAT THE NEO NECKS
ARE ENDEMIC IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND THAT IS A REALLY BIG
PROBLEM- THE AUTHOR IS DEDICATED
TO MAKING SURE. THAT THE OUR OUR
ARMS GROWS ARE CITRUS GROVES ARE
PER ARE AND YOU KNOW IT IN TERMS
OF THE OPPOSITION YOU HAVE TO
BUT ASK. AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
SMARTEST PEOPLE I KNOW. AND A
VERY GOOD LEGISLATOR SHE WAS
BORN TO BE A LEGISLATOR- I AM
SURE. THAT THE- THAT WE WILL END
UP WITH THE BILL THAT PROTECTS
OUR CITRUS OUR AGRICULTURE
ENTERING CHECKS NOT JUST
POLLINATORS BUT ALL OF THEM THEY
ARE THE BASE OF THE FOOD CHAIN.
SO MR SECRETARY. I HAVE NEVER
FIVE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX
BARRICADE HON THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WORK
BY HI SMITH SMITH NO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I CAN. R. K. HANAI
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI HOLDEN. MATHIS MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
NO VERY GOOD- HAS SO WE CAN LOOK
AT THAT. THAT PASSED THAT'S FIVE
FIVE WE'RE GOOD UP WE NEED FOR
THE SERGEANTS TO BRING MR HOLD
ENOUGH. AND ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO ADD ON WILL START WITH
THE BILL STARTING WITH- CONSENT
CALENDAR AND GO FROM THERE AND-
PLEASE SERGEANTS GET A HOLD OF
MR HOLDEN AND I WILL KEEP THIS
UP UNTIL WE'VE I'VE RECORDED
EVERYONE THAT WANTS TO BE
RECORDED. OKAY STARTING WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. RICHARD VOTING
I OUR REGULAR ARAMBULA HI THERE
CAN I CAN I HOLDEN WALDRON
WALDRON I. I AM NUMBER ONE AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE THE
CURRENT- IS THREE TO ONE PICTURE
VOTING AYE. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
CAN I CAN I HOLDEN. WALDRON
WALDRON HI. IT IS SIX TO ONE.
RIGHT INTO AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
IRWIN THE CURRENT BILL IS THREE
TO ONE SURE VOTING II ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HIGH. HOLDEN MURATSUCHI
HI MURATSUCHI AYE WALDRON
WALDRON I. THAT VOTED. SIX TO
ONE. I AM THREE AB TWENTY SIX OH
ONE. THE CURRENT GOAL IS THREE
TO ONE SURE VOTING II ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CAN- CAN I HOLDEN
MATHIS WALDRON. TO IS FIVE TWO
TWO. I NEVER FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TO ONE. HOLDEN MATHIS
WALDRON. VOTING OKAY IS STILL
FIVE TO ONE. AND THAT IS THAT IS
ALL OF THOSE BILLS ALL RIGHT SO
WE HAVE ALL OF OUR BILLS OUT BUT
I DO WANT TO GIVE MR HOLDEN THE
CHANCE TO VOTE I BELIEVE MISTER
MATHIS- DOES. NOT NECESSARILY
WANT TO GO UP ON THE REST OF THE
BILLS BUT I DO NEED MR HOLDEN
HERE. NOW WE HAVE PASSED THE
MALL SO IF YOU DECIDE IF THERE'S
SOMETHING. CAN'T ATTEND FINE BUT
I. REALLY LIKE HIM TO BE UP HERE
SHE CAN'T. JOHN. WE RECORDED
ABOUT READY FOR WE CANNOT
CALDERON NUMBER FOUR FRIEDMAN
OKAY HI MISTER SMITH POWERHOUSE
TWENTY FIFTH NOW. I THOUGHT
COULD BE A NON VOTING DOUBLE
CHECKING AB RECOMMENDED MR
EGGMAN BACK. PART OF COUNTRY'S
YES I HAD AS TO WHO PRESENTING
IN THE MEAN. I'LL WAIT TILL HE'S
A- WELL WHAT I WOULD I A TWO
THIRDS. YEAH AROUND SO LONG AS
HE'S WELL I TO CHANGE.
ALL RIGHT WAIRARAPA. WE NOW HAVE
MR HOLDEN HERE- ALL THE- THE
BILLS HAVE PASSED SO NO PRESSURE
. AND THAT WILL START TO THE
SECRETARY WILL. START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND MOVED
THROUGH ALL THE BILLS AND WE'RE
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE GLAD WE
WAITED FOR YOU. OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AS THE CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT TWO ZERO HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
I. I REMEMBER ONE AB NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN THE
CURRENT GOAL IS SIX TO ONE.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. AS LONG AS THE
ONE IS NOT THE CHAIR. IT A I
DON'T NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY AT THE CURRENT GOAL IS SIX
TO ONE SHARE VOTING AYE. HOLDEN
THEN I. I DON'T NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY SIX OH ONE THE CURRENT-
IS FIVE TO CHAIR VOTING AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I. I DON'T NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE
FRIEDMAN THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TO ONE CHAIR VOTING AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I. AN ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX
PARA QUE HAN THE CURRENT- IS
FIVE TO TWO CHAIR VOTING II
HOLDEN. WELL THEN I. AND THAT IS
ALL THE RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE ALL BUSY PRESENTING
BELLS AND ALL THAT SO- BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU MADE
THE TIME TO COME UP FOR AIR
THANKS FOR HOLDING OUT FOR ME.
GOOD LUCK. I CALL THE COMMITTEE
TO A CLOSE.